Good morning my darling, I'm telling you this To let you know that I'm sorry you're sick Though tears of sorrow won't do you no good I'd be your doctor if only I could What do you want from the liquor store? Something sour or something sweet I'll buy you all that your belly can hold You can be sure you won't suffer no more.
早上好，亲爱的，我告诉你这些是想让你知道，我很遗憾你生病了。虽然悲伤的泪水对你毫无帮助，但如果可以，我真想成为你的医生。你想从酒铺买点什么？酸的还是甜的？我会买下你肚子能装得下的所有东西，你可以确信你再也不会受苦了。
I'd swim the ocean or the deepest canal, to get to you darling just to make you well. There's no place on earth I would hasten to go. To cool the fever, this I want you to know. Hey, I'm here with Tim Faust. Thank you so much for joining us on Taproot Therapy Collective's Discover Heal Grow podcast. We're going to talk about some of the effects of Medicaid,
我会游过海洋或最深的海峡，只为来到你身边，让你康复。这世上没有我不想去的地方，只为帮你退烧，这一点我想让你知道。嘿，我和蒂姆·福斯特（Tim Faust）在一起。非常感谢你参加Taproot Therapy Collective的“发现、治愈、成长”（Discover Heal Grow）播客。我们将讨论一些关于医疗补助（Medicaid）的影响，
how that system works. You have arcane knowledge of the secrets of Medicaid. Could you give us a little bit of your history and share some of that with us? Yeah. It makes things seem complicated. My name is Timothy Faust. I'm a healthcare writer. I write some articles. I write some policy. I wrote a book. I've told a lot of the past seven years. I've been traveling around the U.S. talking to folks about healthcare and how health policy shapes things in their life. Right? Healthcare policy is pretty
以及那个系统是如何运作的。你对医疗补助的秘密有着深奥的了解。你能给我们讲讲你的背景，并分享一些这方面的知识吗？好的。这让事情看起来很复杂。我叫蒂莫西·福斯特。我是一名医疗保健作家。我写一些文章，写一些政策。我还写了一本书。过去七年里，我一直在美国各地旅行，与人们谈论医疗保健以及卫生政策如何塑造他们的生活。对吧？医疗保健政策非常
mentalized, right? What healthcare needs lookss looks like in Birmingham and Meraki, where I live, we've got different kinds of means, different kinds of factors. And health care moods in Milwaukee and Northern Wisconsin are different, you know, different kinds of circumstances, economic forces, environmental factors. And so getting an idea what health care looks like on the ground or a place to place has been really wonderful. I've gotten a chance to learn a lot about healthcare all over the country. A lot of your writing is about taking obscure and
令人费解，对吧？在伯明翰和梅拉基（我居住的地方），医疗保健的需求看起来不同，有着不同的手段和因素。而在密尔沃基和威斯康星州北部，医疗保健的情绪则不同，你知道，有着不同的环境、经济力量和环境因素。因此，了解医疗保健在不同地方的实际情况真的非常棒。我有机会了解了全国各地的医疗保健情况。你的很多文章都是关于揭示那些晦涩且
sometimes absurd policy and then clarifying how we got here, and how those things work, or just some of the service gaps and the arbitrary nature of how these things are going. Can you tell us how you got into trying to translate the, I would say the intentionally obscure healthcare policy of the US into layman's terms? Because it seems like a very good way to democratize information and empower people to understand what legislation means for them.
有时荒谬的政策，并阐明我们是如何走到这一步的，这些事情是如何运作的，或者仅仅是关于服务缺口以及这些事情运作方式的随意性。你能告诉我们你是如何开始尝试将美国那些故意晦涩难懂的医疗保健政策翻译成外行能听懂的语言的吗？因为这似乎是普及信息并赋予人们理解立法对他们意味着什么的非常好的方式。
How did you identify that as kind of an issue and go? In 2013 and 2014, I had a job in Florida and with people in the Affordable Care Act in Florida, Georgia and Texas. And you know, I didn't know a lot about health policy. I wanted to learn what was going on. And I knew that having insurance was important. I had been on Medicare a couple of years prior for an accident and it was crazy. So they gave me a chance to not go under a five-year credit card debt. And so I thought, okay, well, I'll get involved in this. Both three gap states chose not to expand Medicaid.
你是如何发现这是一个问题的？在2013年和2014年，我在佛罗里达州有一份工作，与佛罗里达州、佐治亚州和得克萨斯州的《平价医疗法案》（Affordable Care Act）相关人员共事。你知道，我对卫生政策了解不多。我想了解发生了什么。我知道拥有保险很重要。几年前我因为一次事故使用过医疗保险（Medicare），那真是太疯狂了。所以他们给了我一个不至于背负五年信用卡债务的机会。于是我想，好吧，我会参与其中。那三个拒绝扩张医疗补助的州选择了不扩大覆盖范围。
So I kept running into people who didn't qualify for an insurance, they didn't get money to give them a credit to buy insurance because they didn't make enough money to qualify for um, they didn't see the exedit and money to give them credits to buy insurance because they didn't make enough money with to call for subsidies but made too much money to qualify for Medicaid and that whole existence and a class of people who had those two players and two bosses for help getting health care uh can't really get anything i mean now to process that then i spent the next couple of years doing research, talking to folks. It's actually found that there was a meeting,
所以我不断遇到那些没有资格获得保险的人，他们没有得到钱来购买保险，因为他们的收入不足以获得补贴，但收入又太高，无法获得医疗补助。那种存在状态，以及那些既没有保险又没有雇主帮助获得医疗保健的人，真的什么也得不到。我的意思是，处理完这些后，我花了接下来的几年时间做研究，与人们交谈。实际上我发现有一个会议，
people would talk about health care and regular person race. I can do this. I've got some of the background, I've got some of the information, I read a lot, I really love health care. Why not go out there and talk to folks about health care language that more people can use. The system is very complicated for a lot of very silly reasons, right?
人们会用普通人的语言谈论医疗保健。我可以做到这一点。我有一定的背景，我有信息，我读了很多书，我真的很热爱医疗保健。为什么不走出去，用更多人能听懂的语言与人们谈论医疗保健呢？这个系统因为很多非常愚蠢的原因而变得非常复杂，对吧？
Like, yeah, the way you run healthcare in America, it was not a very new design has to be run, if you had any sort of matter you were designing it from scratch. You would never just sit down with a protractor and a spreadsheet and say, I want to design a system that works and then end up with anything that looks like what we do today. Absolutely not.
就像，是的，你在美国运营医疗保健的方式，如果从头开始设计，它绝不是一种新的设计。如果你有任何理智，你会从零开始设计它。你绝不会坐下来拿着量角器和电子表格说，我想设计一个有效的系统，然后最终得到一个像我们今天这样运作的东西。绝对不会。
And it's a series of historical accidents and one-off agreements that got entrenched, piracy of the systems, most famously during World War II, there was a wage freeze. And so, in order to attract new workers and players to get an offering of insurance as an employment perk, we kind of had to become the backbone of how
这是一系列历史性的意外和一次性协议根深蒂固的结果，是系统的盗版，最著名的是在二战期间，当时实行了工资冻结。因此，为了吸引新员工并提供保险作为就业福利，我们不得不将其作为一种支柱，
a third device could get our insurance. There was a bunch of accidents over time. As a result, we got this very messy, very silly, very routine, hard to follow model. One of the things that I bump up against, because I'm a social worker, so I was on a sort of community treatment team, working with some of the most seriously
第三种方式来获得保险。随着时间的推移，发生了一连串的意外。结果，我们得到了这个非常混乱、非常愚蠢、非常常规、难以遵循的模型。我遇到的问题之一是，因为我是一名社会工作者，我曾在某种社区治疗团队工作，与州里一些最严重的
mental health people in the state, and billing Medicaid for that when I first started before we had the complex trauma practice. And like, what I find is that a lot of times the people at the top, you know, the politicians, or the sort of journalists with an axe to grind or a political agenda. They'll make these arguments that sort of like sound like they make sense, but when
精神健康问题患者共事，并在我刚开始工作、还没有复杂创伤实践之前，为这些服务向医疗补助计费。我发现很多时候，高层的人，你知道，政客们，或者那些有个人目的或政治议程的记者，他们会提出一些听起来很有道理的论点，但当你
you dig into them, you know, and most people just kind of think that that's true and they're like, oh, okay, you cut Medicaid, you save money or something. But when you dig into it, it's like that's what the voter base thinks that it works that way. But when you talk to those politicians, like they know that it doesn't really, they just know that people are susceptible to certain lines of argument. Like when I was on the assertive community treatment team, we took people who were chronically homeless and had been in and out of the state mental
深入挖掘时，你知道，大多数人只是认为那是真的，他们会说，哦，好吧，你削减医疗补助，你就能省钱之类的。但当你深入研究时，这就是选民认为它运作的方式。但当你与那些政客交谈时，他们知道事实并非如此，他们只是知道人们容易受到某些论点的影响。就像我在断言社区治疗团队（Assertive Community Treatment team）工作时，我们接收了那些长期无家可归，并且多年来进出州立精神
facility for years with no improvement. And Medicaid's like, okay, we'll pay a higher rate for assertive community treatment because these people cost so much money, you know. And they're going to the ER all the time and they're saying, I'm the King of England and then the ER gives them a sandwich and says, here's a script that you can't afford for a disease you don't understand with support you don't have and money you don't have to fill the prescription for an antipsychotic and then they come back the next day or later that day.
设施且没有任何改善的人。医疗补助说，好吧，我们会为断言社区治疗支付更高的费用，因为这些人花费了太多的钱，你知道。他们总是去急诊室，他们说，我是英国国王，然后急诊室给他们一个三明治，并说，这是一张你买不起的处方，针对一种你不了解的疾病，而你没有支持，也没有钱去填补抗精神病药物的处方，然后他们第二天或当天晚些时候又回来了。
A doctor did a study on that group when I was there and they were like, do you realize that you've got 13 people, you've got three nurses, you've got a psychiatrist, and you've got all these social workers, which are pretty cheap. I think I was making like 35,000 a year at that point. And they see about 150 people a year, give or take 20. And that for every one of those people
我在那里时，一位医生对那个群体做了一项研究，他们说，你意识到你有13个人，你有三名护士，你有一名精神科医生，还有所有这些社会工作者，他们相当便宜。我想那时我一年赚大约35,000美元。他们一年大约看150人，上下浮动20人。而对于这些人中的每一个人，
that this 13 person team is able to see, you saved the state Medicaid system a million dollars, right? You know, so it's like, okay, well, this makes sense. You know, the politicians are saying that they want to cut this and all the stuff. Well, like, you know, you're paying me $30,000. I'm giving you a million times, you know, seven, eight people. I'm giving, like, if this is about money, this is a pretty clear thing. And yet they would come back and say, no, we need to cut it. We don't want to have this, because it's not really about the money. You know, it's about, you know, people assuming that they want the voter base to assume that it's
这个13人的团队能够照顾到，你就为州医疗补助系统节省了一百万美元，对吧？你知道，所以这就像，好吧，这很有道理。你知道，政客们说他们想削减这个和那个。好吧，你知道，你付给我3万美元。我为你节省了一百万，你知道，七八个人。我的意思是，如果这是关于钱的问题，这是一个非常清楚的事情。然而他们会回来并说，不，我们需要削减它。我们不想有这个，因为这实际上不是关于钱的问题。你知道，这是关于，你知道，人们假设他们希望选民认为这是
about the money. But really, a lot of people just don't want these systems to exist. I think. Well, I mean, I talked to a lot of episode and I'd say half of them are doing exactly what you say. And I was using, you know, like, buzzwords or marketing, I know, but they know people might like because it sounds reasonable. Say on behalf of them, yeah, I straight up any any logs or even works to have my liberal and I fired them themselves there that the deadlines that that they've been given. The return of Medicaid and those patients you talked about is that
关于钱的问题。但实际上，很多人只是不希望这些系统存在。我想。好吧，我的意思是，我谈论了很多集，我会说其中一半的人正在做你所说的。我当时在用，你知道，比如，流行语或营销，我知道，但他们知道人们可能会喜欢，因为它听起来很合理。代表他们说，是的，我直接……任何日志甚至工作，我有我的自由派，我解雇了他们自己，他们被给出的最后期限。你谈到的医疗补助和那些病人的回报是，
private insurance will be an option for a lot of these people because they're too extensive to take care of. And the entire backbone of the way the insurance system in the US works is that health care costs a lot of money, so a lot of reasons we could talk about, and it's not very profitable to sell insurance to people who need it in the health care. As the empire of private insurance is, we all put money into a big pot, and then part of that pot is used to pay for health care for people who need it. Because health care costs millions and millions from year to year for a person, right?
私人保险对这些人中的许多人来说将是一个选择，因为他们太昂贵了，无法照顾。美国保险系统运作的整个支柱是，医疗保健花费很多钱，所以有很多原因我们可以谈论，向需要医疗保健的人出售保险并不是很赚钱。作为私人保险的帝国，我们都把钱放进一个大罐子里，然后那个罐子的一部分被用来为需要的人支付医疗保健费用。因为医疗保健对一个人来说，年复一年地花费数百万，对吧？
Sometimes some really don't want to be out there at all and some of us should be hit by a car or you know, get pneumonia or cancer or something like that. And you need a lot of health care, you need a lot of money. But there's no way you could pay the 20,000, 50,000, a hundred thousand dollar like hospitalization machines and you're on. So the idea is we have to then, and when we need it, we take money out. But insurance companies, you gotta make money.
有时有些人根本不想在那里，有些人会被车撞，或者你知道，患上肺炎或癌症之类的。你需要大量的医疗保健，你需要大量的钱。但你不可能支付2万、5万、10万美元的住院机器费用，而你还在上面。所以想法是，我们必须然后，当我们需要它时，我们取出钱。但是保险公司，你必须赚钱。
And the way they make money is by paying less on care and they'll receive end premiums. So if you have somebody who is poor and can't put a lot of money in the pot, or you're somebody who has anxiety, unless you've got cancer, Poor they can't put a lot of money in the pot or you're somebody who has a chronic illness You know you've you've got cancer. He's got a pediatric disarbor that that happens throughout time. You've got a mental health problem It's gonna cost a lot more
他们赚钱的方式是支付更少的护理费用，他们会收到保费。所以如果你有一个穷人，不能往罐子里放很多钱，或者你是一个有焦虑症的人，除非你得了癌症，穷人不能往罐子里放很多钱，或者你是一个有慢性病的人，你知道你得了癌症。他有儿科疾病，随着时间的推移会发生。你有心理健康问题，这会花费更多
Perfectly the health care that he doesn't be able to pay for premiums We've seen that which for a long time didn't get a health care. They were excluded from insurance models, right? Now we have a standard saying that, you know, publicly you can't be turned down for buying insurance if you have a pre-existing condition. But there's lots of other ways to exclude people from getting insurance. Telling screenings, you started to see those after Obamacare. Well, just denying care altogether, right?
完美地，他无法支付保费的医疗保健。我们已经看到了这一点，长期以来没有得到医疗保健。他们被排除在保险模式之外，对吧？现在我们有一个标准说，你知道，公开地，如果你有既往症，你不能被拒绝购买保险。但还有很多其他方式可以将人们排除在保险之外。筛选，你在奥巴马医改（Obamacare）之后开始看到这些。好吧，只是完全拒绝护理，对吧？
There's lots of ways to live around as paying for somebody's house care, even if you're, you know, in Syria, you can shout, say, I'm a little bit for it. And so because we really want these people to be abandoned for a variety of reasons, one was very expensive and costs a lot of problems for all of us. Two, I think it's fundamentally unjust to let these companies forget how to caring for people. We have programs like Medicaid, which pays for low income people,
有很多方法可以绕过支付某人的医疗保健，即使你，你知道，在叙利亚，你可以大喊，说，我为此付了一点钱。所以因为我们真的希望这些人被遗弃，原因有很多，一是太贵了，给我们所有人造成了很多问题。二，我认为让这些公司忘记如何照顾人是根本不公正的。我们有像医疗补助这样的项目，它为低收入人群支付费用，
people who are really sick, and Medicare, which covers senior citizens who tends to need a lot more healthcare than people under age 50 or whatever. And so we built these government programs that basically take care of people the private market would never be able to. And I'd say that there's a lot of people out there still who the private market can't take very good care of but they're still locked into the system. But it's a way of like recognizing that healthcare costs are entirely unaffordable for market people. You know, once you got 10 million dollars in the bank you probably can't pay for
那些真正生病的人，以及医疗保险（Medicare），它覆盖了往往比50岁以下的人需要更多医疗保健的老年人。所以我们建立了这些政府项目，基本上照顾了私人市场永远无法照顾的人。我想说，外面还有很多人，私人市场无法很好地照顾他们，但他们仍然被锁定在系统中。但这是一种认识到医疗保健成本对市场人士来说完全负担不起的方式。你知道，一旦你银行里有1000万美元，你可能就无法支付
that healthcare. And finding a way to both take care of them versus invest money into the parts of the country where real differences are made. Like if you live in a rural area, I live in Wisconsin, Wisconsin, you know, half of us live in rural areas, it's not profitable to build a hospital in a rural area. Right? Because you might get it, isn't growing up between any wood,
那笔医疗保健费用。并找到一种既能照顾他们，又能将资金投入到国家真正能产生差异的地方的方法。比如如果你住在农村地区，我住在威斯康星州，威斯康星州，你知道，我们一半人住在农村地区，在农村地区建医院是不赚钱的。对吧？因为你可能会得到它，不是在木头之间长大的，
like you're supposed to deliver kids, you're not getting, you know, 10 births a day if you live in a rural area, because there's just not enough people in the area. So hospitals don't want to build facilities in rural areas. They want to close those facilities and put the money into a wealthy areas where there's more people, like suburbs. We shouldn't put stress on cities like Birmingham when you've got people driving from Mobile to come to UAB. It's going to put stress on cities like Birmingham when you've got people driving from Mobile to come to UAB.
就像你应该接生孩子一样，你没有，你知道，如果你住在农村地区，一天10次分娩，因为该地区的人不够多。所以医院不想在农村地区建设设施。他们想关闭这些设施，把钱投入到人口更多的富裕地区，比如郊区。当人们从莫比尔（Mobile）开车来UAB时，我们不应该给伯明翰这样的城市增加压力。当人们从莫比尔开车来UAB时，这会给伯明翰这样的城市增加压力。
It's going to affect the city eventually. A lot of the people that are in the city maybe feel safe from some of these cuts, but when the system is under strain, when there's service gaps, it affects everybody negatively. entire program. And Medi-Pay is the one insurer in the country that puts most of the money into rural high-skill providers or rural high-skill clinics. About 50% of rural clinics and rural hospitals are just barely breaking even or even in the web. And Medicaid is the one thing keeping them from closing. We saw in in states that didn't expand Medicaid, it was three times higher rate of real hospital closures than we saw in states that didn't expect Medicaid. It's like a backbone for how you pay for health care
这最终会影响城市。城市里的许多人可能觉得这些削减是安全的，但当系统处于压力之下，当出现服务缺口时，它会对每个人产生负面影响。整个项目。而医疗补助是全国唯一一个将大部分资金投入到农村高技能提供者或农村高技能诊所的保险公司。大约50%的农村诊所和农村医院只是勉强收支平衡，甚至处于亏损状态。而医疗补助是防止它们关闭的唯一因素。我们在没有扩大医疗补助的州看到，农村医院关闭率是我们在没有预期医疗补助的州看到的三倍。它就像你支付医疗保健费用的支柱
in areas where it's not profitable to either offer or pay for your health care. Well, and I mean, when you're saying that they can't afford to take care of these people, I mean, I think you mean like private insurance cannot make money off of them. It's not profitable for private insurance. But like a lot of times, I think Medicaid expansion gets framed in kind of lefty language of human rights and that these people have a right to healthcare.
在那些提供或支付医疗保健费用都不赚钱的地区。好吧，我的意思是，当你说是他们负担不起照顾这些人时，我的意思是，我想你的意思是私人保险无法从他们身上赚钱。这对私人保险来说是不赚钱的。但很多时候，我认为医疗补助扩张被框定在某种左翼的人权语言中，即这些人有权获得医疗保健。
I definitely believe that. But even if you don't, I mean, when you just look at this model as a business, when you are not taking care of certain people in a country that you are tasked with running as a business, when you are not taking care of certain people in a country that you are tasked with running as a politician, you're going to make things more expensive when you don't take care of some people. I think there's a business case to be made too for why Medicaid, what cutting Medicaid is bad for everybody. So when people tend to serve healthcare, when they're on the hook for costs, they're totally
我绝对相信这一点。但即使你不相信，我的意思是，当你只是把这个模型看作一门生意时，当你没有照顾国家中某些你被委以经营重任的人时，当你没有照顾国家中某些你被委以经营重任的政客时，当你没有照顾某些人时，你会让事情变得更昂贵。我认为有一个商业案例可以说明为什么削减医疗补助对每个人都是有害的。所以当人们倾向于服务医疗保健时，当他们承担成本时，他们完全
on the same level as everybody, they're just saying, get healthcare. That's why we've got a huge medical debt pattern in the US. One third of our families have spent on medical debt. So, some of them have medical debt over a thousand dollars. And yet there are in debt when there are sort of costs and that goes across the board. We see all kinds of people, even higher income people, have medical debt now. They just don't get healthcare, which means problems get worse and worse and worse and they faster until all of a sudden,
和每个人处于同一水平，他们只是说，获得医疗保健。这就是为什么我们在美国有一个巨大的医疗债务模式。我们三分之一的家庭有医疗债务。所以，他们中的一些人有超过一千美元的医疗债务。然而，当有某种成本时，他们就负债了，这在各方面都是如此。我们看到各种各样的人，甚至是高收入的人，现在也有医疗债务。他们只是没有得到医疗保健，这意味着问题变得越来越严重，越来越快，直到突然之间，
you're dying from stage four cancer, you get rushed to the ER, and they spend so much money to take care of that person at the end of their lives. Her husband, and someone they could have had a life, just because preventative care is not funded. We avoid these things, we're accessible. We avoid these things,
你死于四期癌症，你被送往急诊室，他们花费了大量的钱在他们生命的尽头照顾那个人。她的丈夫，以及他们本可以拥有的生活，仅仅因为预防性护理没有得到资助。我们避免这些事情，我们是可及的。我们避免这些事情，
and then it is a more expensive problem to treat, you know. I want to have to now save money down the road. That's a, you know, the next basically people can live longer and better lives, which is good for all of us. Right. So then we've got a family member, you know, one in five people out of them are on Medicaid, about 20.1%. And it's a pretty variable mix.
然后这是一个更昂贵的治疗问题，你知道。我想现在在路上省钱。这是一个，你知道，接下来基本上人们可以活得更长、更好，这对我们所有人都有好处。对。所以我们有一个家庭成员，你知道，五分之一的人在医疗补助上，大约20.1%。这是一个相当多变的组合。
Again, like some rules, you lose your job, some years you get a job, some years you get hit by a car, some years you don't see a doctor at all. It's like this pretty shifting, pretty remorseful population. You know, I was on Medicare for a couple of years in California, but I resumed Medicare a couple of years later in Texas. It's like, you know, our lives can change a lot, but they look very differently from year to year. And so people kind of float in and out of Medicare the same way they might float in and out of
同样，就像一些规则，你失去了工作，有些年你得到了一份工作，有些年你被车撞了，有些年你根本没看医生。这就像这个相当转移、相当后悔的人口。你知道，我在加利福尼亚州使用医疗保险几年，但我几年后在得克萨斯州恢复了医疗保险。这就像，你知道，我们的生活可以改变很多，但它们年复一年看起来非常不同。所以人们以同样的方式漂进漂出医疗保险，就像他们可能漂进漂出
as an internment or whatever, right? Mm-hmm. And if you happen to be on Medicare in the given year and you start getting a weird cost, which is definitely what happened to me. I had a weird cost. I knew it because I had already paid a bunch of money in health care.
作为实习生之类的，对吧？嗯嗯。如果你恰好在某一年使用医疗保险，并且你开始得到一个奇怪的费用，这绝对是我发生的事情。我有一个奇怪的费用。我知道它，因为我已经支付了很多医疗保健费用。
But I was afraid this could go further into debt. I had to kind of ruin my credit by having to pay my bills and my credit card, but I didn't have insurance, so I didn't have a choice but to buy it. And I had my cough, so it got a little bit worse, it got a little bit worse. Until one day I woke up with a fever that was 103 or 104 degrees, which was much higher than what's supposed to be. And my window rashes moved with the EDI. They bring me and I had double pneumonia. I had pneumonia twice, two parts of my lungs, which to me, like I was threatening condition, just you're not like, you know, for some people, I already had something better as well, I had to get it as well at times, so I put a bit of concern. So they bring me in, they
但我担心这会进一步陷入债务。我不得不通过支付账单和信用卡来毁掉我的信用，但我没有保险，所以我别无选择，只能买它。我有我的咳嗽，所以它变得更糟了一点，它变得更糟了一点。直到有一天我醒来时发烧到103或104华氏度，这比应该的要高得多。我的窗户皮疹随着EDI移动。他们带我进去，我得了双重肺炎。我得了两次肺炎，肺部的两个部分，对我来说，就像我威胁的情况，只是你不是像，你知道，对有些人来说，我已经有更好的东西了，我也得过几次，所以我有点担心。所以他们带我进去，他们
keep me over and let me pump me fill with fluids. And when I leave, I leave to get it as no time. So today I put a big concern. So bring me in, they keep me open, right? They're probably filled with fluids. And when I leave, I leave to like a five or $10,000 hospital bill. And I would have completely ruined my life. Right? I was making, I was working three jobs and I was still making $14,000 a year. Um, cause it was during the financial crisis that I was working with a bunch of minimum wage jobs and when all with me, you know,
留住我，让我充满液体。当我离开时，我离开时没有时间。所以今天我有点担心。所以带我进去，他们留住我，对吧？他们可能充满了液体。当我离开时，我离开时就像一张五到一万美元的医院账单。我会完全毁了我的生活。对。我当时在做，我做了三份工作，我一年仍然赚14,000美元。嗯，因为是在金融危机期间，我做了很多最低工资的工作，当所有人都和我在一起时，你知道，
like four brothers and three girls kind of cobbling things together. And actually, while I was leaving, I woke up at the hospital and said, okay, well, you might be eligible for Medicare. You just expanded Medicare, let's do some paperwork. And thank God I was, because I was sending my birds up to zero,
就像四个兄弟和三个女孩拼凑东西一样。实际上，当我离开时，我在医院醒来并说，好吧，你可能有资格获得医疗保险。你刚刚扩大了医疗保险，让我们做一些文书工作。谢天谢地，我是，因为我把我的鸟儿送到零，
and I was able to have, like the only reason I have the rest that I have, you know, I've got a race that I love very much. I've got a little family that I love very much. I've got a dog that I love very much. I can do what's interesting to me. If he calls, I will put under the burden of, you know, buying single medical records when I was 23.
我能够拥有，就像我拥有的休息的唯一原因，你知道，我有一个我非常喜欢的种族。我有一个我非常爱的小家庭。我有一只我非常爱的狗。我可以做我感兴趣的事情。如果他打电话，我会被，你知道，当我23岁时购买单一医疗记录的负担所困。
I was able to do things and take jobs and go places that had made my life better and richer and more interesting. And I've made my friends' lives even better, have an impact and arise other people around me only because I wasn't thrust under all that at a vulnerable point in my life. And a working person who is part of the economy in a good way.
我能够做事情，接受工作，去那些让我的生活更好、更丰富、更有趣的地方。我让我的朋友们的生活变得更好，产生影响，并提升我周围的其他人的生活，仅仅是因为我没有在我生命中脆弱的时刻被推入所有这些。以及一个作为经济一部分的劳动者，以一种好的方式。
I mean, half the people, half the reason some of the brilliant people that I work with in therapy, um, are not going back to school, are not kind of pursuing the thing that they're totally interested in and capable of doing is medical debt. I mean, they're, they're, they're, the medical debt is what stops them from accruing the educational debt that they might be able to pay off, you know, with the job that they're definitely qualified to do, but they're stuck in a restaurant
我的意思是，我一起工作的那些在治疗中非常出色的人，有一半的原因，嗯，没有回到学校，没有追求他们完全感兴趣和有能力做的事情，是医疗债务。我的意思是，他们，他们，医疗债务是阻止他们积累他们可能能够偿还的教育债务的东西，你知道，用他们绝对有资格做的工作，但他们被困在餐馆里
or they're stuck driving an Uber. Yeah. It's the absence of the metal to metal costs. So what are the biggest causes of bankruptcy? I think actually the biggest cause of bankruptcy in the US. How much of your workforce are you losing when you're just taking the smartest people who may not be born with a ton of money, but are totally capable of doing this stuff and not giving them a pathway to, to go do it.
或者他们被困在开优步（Uber）。是的，这是金属对金属成本的缺失。那么破产的最大原因是什么？我认为实际上是美国破产的最大原因。当你只是带走那些可能不是带着大量金钱出生，但完全有能力做这些事情的最聪明的人，而不给他们一条去做的途径时，你失去了多少劳动力。
And you know, you mentioned some of the silly things in Medicaid. So we've got this such as they're like, you know, overriding beliefs that only some people deserve government programs or whatever. So you need to find the exact line of income, you know, $12,800 or whatever, a broad rich people don't receive benefits in the way which they do. That means you don't take a promotion, you don't take on their orders, you don't take on their work. I was talking to a guy in upstate Wisconsin
而且你知道，你提到了医疗补助中的一些愚蠢的事情。所以我们有这样的，比如，你知道，压倒性的信念，即只有一些人应该得到政府项目之类的。所以你需要找到收入的确切界限，你知道，12,800美元之类的，广泛的富人不会以他们那样的方式获得福利。这意味着你不接受晋升，你不接受他们的订单，你不接受他们的工作。我当时正在和威斯康星州北部的一个人交谈
who's a comrade who makes shoes for people who have prosthetic legs. Great job. Super important. A job I never thought about investing until I talked to this guy. And he's got multiple sclerosis. So he needs Medicaid to get all his medications, cover his hospital bills.
他是一个同志，为有假肢的人制作鞋子。伟大的工作。超级重要。一份我直到和这个人交谈之前从未想过要投资的工作。他患有多发性硬化症。所以他需要医疗补助来获得他所有的药物，支付他的医院账单。
He's a very lucky person. he wants to do his job. His job is important. It's very social, helps everybody. But if he takes on too many clients, if he does too much work, he stops being eligible for medical. He includes who would die because no private insurance will cover all the bills and the cost he can afford to get the healthcare he needs. So in the total, right, so he has several options.
他是一个非常幸运的人。他想做他的工作。他的工作很重要。它非常社交，帮助每个人。但如果他承担太多的客户，如果他做太多的工作，他就不再有资格获得医疗。他包括那些会死的人，因为没有私人保险会支付所有的账单和费用，他负担得起获得他需要的医疗保健。所以总的来说，对，所以他有几个选择。
Work fewer hours care he needs. So the total rate with serious medical options works even hours with guys, you know? And this time of model where we really limit public health care, public programs to just the poorest of the poorest. And most of them are working, I think, but 92 to 98% of people who are in Medicaid are working cow jobs or are in school or are caregivers full time for somebody at home
工作更少的时间，他需要的护理。所以总的来说，有严重的医疗选择，工作更少的时间，你知道？在这个我们真正限制公共医疗保健、公共项目仅限于最贫穷的穷人的模型中。而且他们中的大多数人都在工作，我想，但92%到98%的医疗补助参与者都在做牛马工作，或者在学校，或者是在家全职照顾某人
who has a convalescent or whatever. You know, you put a cap on their ability or I can get a full time for somebody at home or as a kind of a lesser. You know, what a cat. I'm not going to need to take on more hours or do more kinds of work. We'll restrict Medicaid to just, you know, the hyper poor or the super low income. It's kind of deceptive. That's not what you would have done
有康复期之类的。你知道，你限制了他们的能力，或者我可以全职在家照顾某人，或者作为一种较小的。你知道，什么猫。我不需要承担更多的时间或做更多种类的工作。我们将医疗补助限制在仅，你知道，超级穷人或超低收入者。这有点欺骗性。这不是你会做的
to a very interesting society if you had the option to do it from scratch. Well, I mean, in my lifetime, like I my lifetime, I've wanted to hear somebody advocate the need for broad universal programs, not just healthcare, but just these are the baseline of what you get as a citizen that pays taxes. I think even more so than the Republicans, I mean, the Democrats in my lifetime, it's like every time these things come up,
如果你有选择从零开始做一个非常有趣的社会。好吧，我的意思是，在我的一生中，就像我的一生中，我想听到有人倡导对广泛的普遍项目的需求，不仅仅是医疗保健，而只是这些是你作为纳税公民得到的基准。我认为甚至比共和党人更甚，我的意思是，民主党人在我的一生中，就像每次这些事情出现时，
oh, we're going to do it responsibly. We're going to means test. We're going to meter. We're going to have caps. We're going to make sure that you're somehow eligible. We just can't have public education. We can't have public health care. Can you speak to the gas lighting
哦，我们要负责任地做。我们要进行经济状况调查。我们要计量。我们要有上限。我们要确保你以某种方式有资格。我们只是不能有公共教育。我们不能有公共医疗保健。你能谈谈煤气灯效应吗
that it feels responsible if we have double, triple means tested filters to stop the wrong person from just being able to get diabetes medication and somehow only get the right people. How that is sort of the self-defeating model of legislation. Sure. Now, this whole notion of deservingness is a really complicated question that we grappled with definitely over the past couple of hundred years. But at the end of the day, like, you know, the obstacles you put in the way of somebody being in a good healthcare or doing a good other benefit programs, the fewer people who are eligible will die.
如果我们要有双重、三重经济状况调查过滤器来阻止错误的人仅仅能够获得糖尿病药物，并以某种方式只让正确的人获得，这感觉很负责任。这如何是立法的自我挫败模型。当然。现在，这种关于应得性的整个概念是一个非常复杂的问题，我们在过去几百年里绝对努力解决过。但归根结底，就像，你知道，你放在某人获得良好医疗保健或做其他良好福利项目道路上的障碍，符合条件的人数就会越少，就会死。
Like I would say, in my day job, I helped them with senior citizens of Medicaid. You know, people who are 65 who are super low income or have a disability. And I am applying for Medicaid in a lot of sense. I've done it professionally for a long time now. I've got software and we've got phone numbers and stuff. And if you still take somebody two or three weeks or even longer to apply for Medicaid, because of the fear that we let somebody in who has too much money or who is on the line and who doesn't actually deserve to get a public program, we put all this paperwork and all these obstacles in the way of getting health care.
就像我会说，在我的日常工作中，我帮助他们处理医疗补助的老年人。你知道，65岁、收入超低或有残疾的人。我正在申请医疗补助，在很多意义上。我已经专业地做了很长时间了。我有软件，我们有电话号码之类的。如果你仍然花某人两到三周甚至更长时间来申请医疗补助，因为担心我们让一个有太多钱的人进来，或者处于边缘且实际上不应该获得公共项目的人，我们把所有这些文书工作和所有这些障碍放在获得医疗保健的道路上。
And if you're a low-income person or you're a senior citizen or you've got a disability, rendering all of your bank statements, you know, your car appellments, your income, all of your social security checks, your social security card, getting all these things together. That's the imparity of the application. Like I don't, if you haven't looked in a Medicaid application and you're listening to this, just go look what you have to fill out, you know, to say that you are disabled, you know, like, or to get SSDI to apply for Medicaid. I mean, it's like you need almost like a team of social workers and a lawyer to apply for some of these programs in some of these states. And sometimes that's exactly what you need, right?
如果你是一个低收入者，或者你是一个老年人，或者你有残疾，提交你所有的银行对账单，你知道，你的汽车评估，你的收入，你所有的社会保障支票，你的社会保障卡，把所有这些东西放在一起。这就是申请的艰巨性。就像我不，如果你没有看过医疗补助申请，而你正在听这个，就去看看你必须填写什么，你知道，来说明你是残疾的，你知道，比如，或者为了获得SSDI来申请医疗补助。我的意思是，这就像你需要一个社会工作者团队和一个律师来在这些州中的一些州申请这些项目。有时这正是你所需要的，对吧？
I mean, do you have social workers with letters who go through this? Because it's so complicated. You know, you say that your taxes are complicated, applying for medical, five times more complicated than a maternity leave tax form, even on a dollar a year. They're willing to grow everything in the entire life to make sure you don't make one dollar more
我的意思是，你有带信的社会工作者来经历这个吗？因为它太复杂了。你知道，你说你的税很复杂，申请医疗补助，比产假税表复杂五倍，即使是一年一美元。他们愿意增长整个生命中的一切，以确保你不会多赚一美元
than the state thinks you should make if you deserve healthcare. And because of that, lots of senior citizens, lots of minimum computer, lots of disabilities fall through the gap. Not because they're not eligible for the program, because they don't have the ability to go back and forth over and over again to sell the temple work. And on top of that, you know, states don't invest money in making rapid searching process smooth. You know, in some states we don't even have a central building that goes connecting all these things together.
比州认为你应该赚的如果你应得医疗保健。正因为如此，许多老年人，许多最低计算机，许多残疾人落入了缺口。不是因为他们没有资格参加该项目，而是因为他们没有能力来回反复地销售寺庙工作。最重要的是，你知道，州政府不投资使快速搜索过程顺利。你知道，在一些州，我们甚至没有一个连接所有这些东西的中央建筑。
Um, in 2025, you know, you're tracked by like 15 different ad companies. Like if your toddler clicks on an app, but we don't have a way to centralize the state's Medicaid system in some of these places. In some places, you got to apply in person. They don't even have a place you can marry or fact-staff or even do it online. There was a good study. So your debt is a state that just passed full requirements for Medicaid, which is another one with paperwork.
嗯，在2025年，你知道，你被大约15家不同的广告公司追踪。就像如果你的蹒跚学步的孩子点击了一个应用程序，但我们没有办法在这些地方集中州的医疗补助系统。在一些地方，你必须亲自申请。他们甚至没有一个你可以结婚或传真甚至在线做的地方。有一个很好的研究。所以你的债务是一个刚刚通过医疗补助全面要求的州，这是另一个文书工作。
You're going to be on Medicaid, you got to work 80 hours a month, which again, everybody was already doing, but now the process of getting the film and filling it out and finding the paper to certify with an uploader, whatever, but it was actually in Georgia a couple of years ago. And they have like the spokesperson, this guy who was a mechanic, who was like, I work 80 hours, I mean, I work really 80 hours a month, if I can can do it anybody can do it and I would of course the next year She was to have been shows three times because the computer system breathed down or the paper after that like the Complexity into this the well whether our work to take
你要参加医疗补助，你必须每月工作80小时，这再次，每个人都已经这样做了，但现在获得电影并填写它并找到纸张来认证上传者之类的过程，但它实际上是几年前在佐治亚州。他们有像发言人，这个家伙是一个机械师，他说，我工作80小时，我的意思是，我真的每月工作80小时，如果我可以做到，任何人都可以做到，我当然明年她被展示了三次，因为计算机系统崩溃了，或者在那之后的纸张，就像复杂性进入这个，好吧，无论我们的工作采取
We're looking in some states, you know in my experience like three to nine months of approval time. It's not like okay You know, they didn't get the form mail it again. It's like you wait nine months before you find out that the form is missing, you know It's just you expand has to repeat the bad meter without having to go through other with them all Well, yeah form with two questions, you know, are you a US citizen and are you a resident of Alabama? you know, are you a US citizen and are you a resident of Alabama? Mm-hmm. It's a done. Um, I, and that sounds a lot of problems, but you know, we've got, you know, um, the insurance industry definitely wanna stop existing.
我们在一些州看到，你知道在我的经验中，像三到九个月的批准时间。这不像好吧，你知道，他们没有得到表格再次邮寄。这就像你等了九个月才发现表格丢失了，你知道，这只是你扩展必须重复坏米，而不必经历其他与他们全部。好吧，是的，有两个问题的表格，你知道，你是美国公民吗，你是阿拉巴马州的居民吗，你知道，你是美国公民吗，你是阿拉巴马州的居民吗？嗯嗯。这是一个完成。嗯，我，这听起来有很多问题，但你知道，我们有，你知道，嗯，保险业绝对想停止存在。
Uh, they send a lot of money to bring it to, to politicians, but it's Democrats and Republicans, um, to, to show why they're an necessary component. You know, fundamentally, you know, the job of the insurance company isn't just to pace it, it's to keep costs down, you know, keep costs manageable. But it's also going to cost skyrocket very faster in the US than they do in other countries, and they skyrocket totally unheard from 7-sec inflation. There's a study of MRI, you know, MRI is the big tube you run when you push the button and it scares you, it bothers you. It's one machine that went to MRI places in Washington DC.
呃，他们寄了很多钱给政客，但这是民主党人和共和党人，嗯，来展示为什么他们是一个必要的组成部分。你知道，从根本上说，你知道，保险公司的工作不仅仅是步伐，它是为了降低成本，你知道，保持成本可控。但它也会比其他国家更快地在成本上飙升，而且它们完全闻所未闻地从7秒通胀中飙升。有一个关于MRI的研究，你知道，MRI是你按下按钮时运行的大管子，它吓坏了你，它困扰了你。这是一台机器，去了华盛顿特区的MRI场所。
And the literal, like exact same machine, like you can call it the same literal machine, can have a five-third cost for a risk based upon which insurer is paying for it, which doctor is around, and what their legal is. I mean hospitals employ an entire billing department of people who just go through and say, well that same service could kind of be construed as six different codes. So your job is to figure out which CPT code is the most expensive one to bill for that sort of meets the criteria for this knee surgery that could be four different things. You know every health care system has that room full of people. You've got this rule between hospitals that want to sell you as much money as possible
而且字面上的，就像完全相同的机器，就像你可以称之为相同的字面机器，可以有五分之一的成本，基于哪个保险公司在支付它，哪个医生在附近，以及他们的法律是什么。我的意思是，医院雇佣了一个完整的计费部门，专门去说，好吧，同样的服务可以被解释为六种不同的代码。所以你的工作是找出哪个CPT代码是为那种符合这种膝盖手术标准的医疗计费最昂贵的代码，这可能是四种不同的事情。你知道每个医疗保健系统都有那个满是人的房间。你有医院之间想要卖给你尽可能多的钱的规则
and insurers who want to pay as little money as possible. And so they've got, you know, across the country, probably tens of thousands, if not hundreds of thousands of people who's job it is to litigate every individual line item. And there's a word who's gonna pay us for it, how much it costs. And ultimately ultimately at the end of the day Well, these companies make more money over the year and the people who are screwed are people like you and me that patients
和想要支付尽可能少钱的保险公司。所以他们有，你知道，在全国范围内，可能有成千上万，如果不是几十万人的工作是诉讼每一个单独的行项目。有一个词是谁要为它付钱，它花费多少。最终最终在一天结束时，好吧，这些公司在一年中赚了更多的钱，而那些被搞砸的人是像你和我这样的病人
Who have to pay for the bills at the end of the day or can get these costs on salary or unjust Dempt upon them this whole matter. They're not cute costs round and it does not provide coverage to anybody So what's the point? In every other country, in the rest, every other country that has a functioning healthcare system, there's some central authority that regulates prices. Because last year, the IM check, prices were styrofoam completely unward from the actual cost of the maker.
谁必须在一天结束时支付账单，或者可以在工资上获得这些成本，或者不公正地强加给他们整个事情。他们不是可爱的成本，它不向任何人提供覆盖。那么重点是什么？在其他每个国家，在其余的，每个拥有功能性医疗保健系统的国家，都有某种中央权威来监管价格。因为去年，IM检查，价格完全脱离了制造者的实际成本。
The cost of the bills form under things like the AMA and things like that, they will start to operate like cartels. They are a monopoly and they set their own rates, which is not something that most professions can do. You see that in instance right now where rural care is being purchased by Irish-themed hospital systems which send close care who knows it's most not
像美国医学会（AMA）这类组织旗下的法案成本，它们开始像卡特尔一样运作。它们是垄断者，设定自己的费率，这是大多数职业无法做到的。你现在就能看到这种情况，农村医疗保健正被爱尔兰主题的医院系统收购，这些系统将护理服务转移走，谁都知道这最不
profitable and shuffle it all into the suburbs usually. Then because we're in a game in town they jack up costs. The cost of your vitamin care hasn't changed you know. A good banter of those. The doctors aren't making more. Doctors are doing more paperwork and leaving the profession and we're getting brain drain in healthcare. But it's not like the doc, I mean doctors make a lot, but it's not like doctor like when the healthcare costs do this it's not like doctors salary are doing that. These things are generally going to enrich people
盈利，通常把它们都推到郊区。然后因为我们是城里唯一的选择，他们就抬高成本。你知道，你的维生素护理成本并没有改变。其中很多都是戏言。医生并没有赚得更多。医生们正在处理更多的文书工作，并离开这个行业，我们正在经历医疗保健领域的人才流失。但这并不是说医生，我的意思是医生赚得很多，但并不是说当医疗成本这样变化时，医生的工资也会那样变化。这些事情通常是为了让那些
who most Americans do not like and do not wanna enrich with the policy decisions that are being made. Because of the backward bias and the system is arranged, if I'm a doctor in like a regular clinic, in your neighborhood, I charge, let's say, I don't know, $50 to get these shots or whatever.
大多数美国人不喜欢、也不想通过正在制定的政策决策来使其致富的人获利。由于这种倒退的偏见和系统的安排，如果我是一名医生，在你们社区的一家普通诊所里，我收费，比如说，我不知道，50美元来打这些针或类似的东西。
If the hospital inspires me, that exact same service in the exact same building now costs $200, the rest of the hospital is better negotiating. The actual price of providing the care hasn't changed, but once the hospital inquires me, the costs come out of nowhere and it's die-rocketing. That's an example of how this whole matter looks. But once the hospital requests me, the costs come out of nowhere and it's die-rocketing. That's an example of how this whole matter works. In every other country, you've got somebody in the middle who says, hang on now, Medicare can pay $30 for shots, but the dollar still makes money, and this is the actual cost of
如果医院收购了我，在同一栋大楼里提供完全相同的服务，现在要花费200美元，医院的其他部分更擅长谈判。提供护理的实际价格并没有改变，但一旦医院收购了我，成本就凭空产生，并呈火箭式上升。这就是整个事情看起来的样子。但一旦医院收购了我，成本就凭空产生，并呈火箭式上升。这就是整个事情运作的方式。在其他所有国家，中间都有一个人说，等等，医疗保险可以为注射支付30美元，但医生仍然能赚钱，这就是实际的
care. And we're going to keep, you know, real costs at, you know, 5% growth a year over this core cost and then adjust it based upon trends and our health care is provided and where costs come from. Every single country, even the ones that have market solutions, have this central press center. We don't have that in the US. We get it to the distribution of private insurance companies who have most things broken up because they're too small and Undoing because they're the paid worthy in the bed as you enter the door to hire premiums to build those costs down And that's a massive problem in American health care
护理成本。我们要保持，你知道，实际成本每年增长5%，然后根据趋势和我们的医疗保健提供方式以及成本来源进行调整。每一个国家，即使是那些有市场解决方案的国家，都有这个中央定价中心。我们在美国没有这个。我们把它分发给私人保险公司，由于它们太小而导致大多数事情支离破碎，而且因为它们在你们进门时就是付费方，所以它们会提高保费来降低这些成本，这是美国医疗保健的一个巨大问题。
And so a thing like a single payer I think like Medicare for all one guarantees coverage for all people But to it addresses those cost concerns by reallocating the spending that we have to pay for care that's essential, put a third price for it, but not get totally extradited by like the draining, you know, that extradition of how prices are set. Well, you know, like a lot of politicians
所以像单一支付者这样的事情，我认为像全民医保，一方面保证了所有人的覆盖范围，但另一方面，它通过重新分配我们为基本护理支付的支出，以合理的价格支付，而不是被那种价格设定方式的榨取所完全剥削，从而解决了这些成本问题。嗯，你知道，像很多政客
and a lot of voters claim to, if you really just cared about the cost of healthcare, there's a lot of things that you could bipartisanly do tomorrow. I would say one of those things is the bulk buying power. Because insurance companies say, hey, your drugs are expensive, we want to cover it, but we're not going to cover it at the money you're charging, so go ahead and give us a break on that. And they use that to negotiate. Medicaid doesn't. Medicaid just walks out. They don't use the bulk buying power of the US government to
和很多选民声称的那样，如果你真的只关心医疗保健的成本，明天有很多事情是可以两党合作完成的。我想其中之一就是批量购买力。因为保险公司说，嘿，你们的药很贵，我们想承保，但我们不会按你们要的价格承保，所以请给我们打个折。他们利用这一点进行谈判。医疗补助计划（Medicaid）却不这样做。医疗补助计划只是走开。他们不利用美国政府的批量购买力来
say we're the biggest healthcare system in the country and we're going to, 20% of Alabama, we're going to play hardball with you to get the price of these drugs down. We don't do that. I mean, too, like you've got, like a lot of the way that these drugs are developed, people are like, well, Pfizer can charge a million dollars a pill because Pfizer paid to develop this stuff. No, they didn't. Half of these drugs, you took taxpayer money and then you paid a private company to make
说我们是全国最大的医疗保健系统，我们要，阿拉巴马州20%的份额，我们要和你们强硬谈判，把这些药的价格降下来。我们不这样做。我的意思是，还有，就像你们有很多这些药物的开发方式，人们会说，好吧，辉瑞公司可以为一个药丸收费一百万美元，因为辉瑞公司支付了开发这些东西的费用。不，他们没有。这些药物中有一半，你们拿了纳税人的钱，然后付钱给一家私营公司来制造
the drug and then they own it. And then they get to say what the US taxpayer has to pay to get it. If I pay for something, I want to own it. If I build you a house, I want you to pay me for the house. But we have a lot of these giveaways to these companies that drive these costs up for everybody for no good reason. I mean, I don't think right, left, anyone who understands that would think that it's a smart system. Yeah, and probably a lot of the research that you're showing is very confirm that
这种药，然后他们就拥有了它。然后他们就可以决定美国纳税人必须支付多少钱才能得到它。如果我为某样东西付了钱，我想拥有它。如果我为你盖了一栋房子，我希望你为这栋房子付钱给我。但我们有很多这种给这些公司的赠品，这无缘无故地推高了所有人的成本。我的意思是，我不认为右派、左派，任何了解这一点的人会认为这是一个聪明的系统。是的，而且你展示的很多研究可能非常证实
unpaid or underpaid grad students at universities are actually doing this research, right? that unpaid or underpaid grad students at universities who actually do these experimental research, right? And then the research is packaged and served by the university to a private company who then takes those results and uses that to build health. So that's the core experimentation, the core like still going out with it even possible. That's by the means by the public sector.
大学里未付薪或低薪的研究生实际上在做这些研究，对吧？大学里未付薪或低薪的研究生实际上在做这些实验研究，对吧？然后研究成果被大学打包并提供给一家私营公司，后者随后获取这些结果并利用它来建立医疗。所以核心实验，核心部分，甚至是否可能实现，都是通过公共部门完成的。
It's just being served to insurance companies at putting them grab a dollar, then it's turned into a product that's served back to us at expiration rates. And yeah, if you've got one route, you know, one payer, whether it's Medicare, Ferrari, or one national insurer, whatever, that's violent with drugs,
它只是被提供给保险公司，让他们赚取美元，然后它被变成一种产品，以过高的价格回馈给我们。是的，如果你有一条路线，你知道，一个支付者，无论是全民医保，还是一个国家保险公司，无论是什么，这对于药物来说是强有力的，
it can do a lot more to bring costs down. I said, listen, if you're gonna sell Robodee, if you're. I said listen if you want to sell Rebode if you want to sell instead if you want to sell rent heart beds or whatever and the rust Well, the one guy that buys it and so we're gonna extract a fair price You know when that makes sense in the market, but then that makes sense for us But the pills they have them 10,000 different insurers that only ensure, you know You know the 20,000 people who have very less negotiating power and very less bargaining strengths than that larger pair. That's, you know, that's not having that similar group
它可以做更多的事情来降低成本。我说，听着，如果你要卖Robodee，如果你要卖。我说听着，如果你想卖Rebode，如果你想卖，如果你想卖心脏支架或任何东西，而其余的，好吧，那个买它的人，所以我们要提取一个公平的价格，你知道，这在市场上是有意义的，但这对我们也有意义。但药丸，他们有10,000个不同的保险公司，只承保，你知道，你知道那20,000个几乎没有谈判能力和议价能力的人，比那个更大的支付者要差。这就是，你知道，没有那个类似的群体
that can represent all that buying power set costs. Also, they'll be in other countries, and that's what works for them. And we just have to, we're just, we're just use model. Why don't we just- It's gonna be pretty inefficient. Because there's a lot of money,
可以代表所有这些购买力来设定成本。此外，他们在其他国家也会这样做，这就是对他们有效的方法。而我们只是，我们只是，我们只是使用模型。为什么我们不只是——这将是非常低效的。因为有很多钱，
and that's not doing it that way, right? We just spend about five trillion dollars in U. in UN House care, that number goes up every year and a huge chunk of that is industrial profit, lobbying values and those administrative costs that just create monolist administrators and work services that exist only because of the way the model is arranged. When Medicare, which is insurance for know, when Medicare, which is insurance for old people, and Medicare, which is so much for local people, was proposed in the 60s,
而且不是那样做的，对吧？我们在美国医疗保健上花费了大约五万亿美元，这个数字每年都在上升，其中很大一部分是行业利润、游说价值和那些行政成本，这些成本仅仅因为模型的安排方式而创造了垄断的管理者和服务。当医疗保险，也就是你知道的，当医疗保险，也就是老年人的保险，以及医疗保险，也就是当地人的保险，在60年代被提议时，
the early May launched that big, massive red-and-white campaign saying this is social medicine, couldn't take care of the agency, we need doctors, it's disastrous. And they tried that exact same talebook over and over and over again. Sometimes it works, sometimes it doesn't, but with the creation of Medicare and Medicaid, all the same, the doctors can probably foresee a lot more patients than they could have said,
美国医学会发起了那场大规模的红白运动，说这是社会化医疗，无法照顾代理人，我们需要医生，这是灾难性的。他们一遍又一遍地尝试完全相同的剧本。有时它有效，有时无效，但随着医疗保险和医疗补助计划的创建，同样，医生可能比他们原本能说的预见到更多的病人，
or that totally adaptive argument. But with resistance to having any kind of oversight, any kind of accountability, across, you know, the millions and the metal with the iron is a sign of lobbying, means there was a pretty high resistance against changing things in those that make sense. Well, and like I've seen, you know, in my lifetime, the reason to cut healthcare, you know, a lot of the, when Medicaid gets cut, the argument is that you have to,
或者那个完全适应性的论点。但由于抵制任何形式的监督、任何形式的问责，跨越，你知道，数百万和中间的铁杆是游说的标志，意味着在那些有意义的事情上改变现状存在相当高的阻力。嗯，就像我看到的，你知道，在我的一生中，削减医疗保健的原因，你知道，很多，当医疗补助计划被削减时，论点是你必须，
I just want to talk for a minute about how economies work, where money goes, you know, even if you don't agree with certain kinds of spending, maybe certain kinds of spending that you don't agree with could be more beneficial to you. Thinking of, what is it, who's the director of like Avatar? The James Cameron. Yeah, yeah.
我只是想花一分钟谈谈经济是如何运作的，钱去了哪里，你知道，即使你不同意某些类型的支出，也许你不同意某些类型的支出可能对你更有利。想到，是什么，谁是像《阿凡达》那样的导演？詹姆斯·卡梅隆。是的，是的。
So like James Cameron was, when they were telling him like, you've like committed to build, you know, you've built all this infrastructure in New Zealand to do all this prep work for these Avatar movies. You've got $4 billion or something in making these movies. They're like the most expensive movies ever made. What if they don't break even? What if they don't make money? He was like, you know what we do with the money when we pay movies?
所以就像詹姆斯·卡梅隆，当他们告诉他时，你已经承诺要建造，你知道，你在新西兰建立了所有这些基础设施来为这些《阿凡达》电影做所有的准备工作。你在制作这些电影上花了40亿美元左右。它们是有史以来最昂贵的电影。如果它们不能回本怎么办？如果它们不赚钱怎么办？他说，你知道我们付电影钱时是怎么处理钱的吗？
We're paying artists, we're paying designers, we're paying crafts people, we give it to people who are using it and it's going back into the economy. So I've got a pretty good track record. I think the movies will make money, but if they don't make money, the money was well spent. And you know, a lot of times, you know, I've seen the military spending that is a lot of times
我们在付给艺术家，我们在付给设计师，我们在付给手工艺人，我们把它给那些正在使用它的人，它又回到了经济中。所以我有一个相当好的记录。我认为电影会赚钱，但如果它们不赚钱，钱也花得值。而且你知道，很多时候，你知道，我看到军事支出，很多时候
where the money goes when Medicaid gets cut, go from the 1980s where they're like, yeah, you know, we paid for a bunch of fighter jets that were way over cost and they kind of don't work. And like there was all this speculative technology and then it turned into, well, you just got to do no bid contracts for these wars and these military contractors will get to charge whatever they want and there's no provision for the government to kind of recoup anything
当医疗补助计划被削减时，钱去了哪里，从1980年代开始，他们就像，是的，你知道，我们为一堆超支且几乎无法工作的战斗机付了钱。就像所有这些投机性的技术，然后它变成了，好吧，你只需要为这些战争签订无投标合同，这些军事承包商就可以随意收费，而且政府没有任何条款可以收回任何东西
if there's waste or abuse. And now it's like we have to build metal or solid weapons and lasers that will never work at all. And when you're giving money to those systems as opposed to healthcare, you know, the money goes away. Like it goes to a hole in the desert where it's lit on fire and it will never really be returned to a local economy. When you're making Medicaid, you're making jobs. You're making skilled jobs in rural places.
如果有浪费或滥用。现在就像我们必须制造永远不会工作的金属固体武器和激光。当你把钱给那些系统而不是医疗保健时，你知道，钱就消失了。就像它进入了沙漠里的一个洞，在那里被点火烧掉，永远不会真正回到当地经济中。当你做医疗补助计划时，你在创造就业机会。你在农村地区创造技术性工作。
You're, you know, a country, the US doesn't have a lot of manufacturing. When you fund this stuff, you're putting money back into not just let's give away free health care because we want to do social justice things, but you're giving it to nurses, to doctors, to techs, to social workers who can be employed to actually do something beneficial in this country. The most common job in Wisconsin is a home health worker. Most folks have paid entirely out of Medicaid. Wisconsin spends 11 billion dollars on Medicaid last year. That money doesn't get lit on fire in front of the desert. That money is, side of it is income, massive economic
你，你知道，一个国家，美国没有太多的制造业。当你资助这些东西时，你投入的钱不仅仅是让我们发放免费医疗，因为我们想做社会正义的事情，而是你把它给了护士、医生、技术人员、社会工作者，他们可以被雇佣来在这个国家真正做一些有益的事情。威斯康星州最常见的工作是家庭健康工作者。大多数人完全由医疗补助计划支付。威斯康星州去年在医疗补助计划上花费了110亿美元。那笔钱没有在沙漠前被点火烧掉。那笔钱，它的一面是收入，巨大的经济
drivers. Every dollar spent on house care is a dollar that at some portion goes to a doctor, nurse, or home health or whatever. It it keeps especially real, just like a silk. It is the economic backbone of a lot of parts of the state and a lot of parts of the country. You know, I sat around 10 years ago, so maybe it's out of date, is that every dollar spent on high-scale quotes for the use of economic activity. So it turns into sales, which would then spend a lot of things
驱动力。在医疗保健上花费的每一美元都是一部分流向医生、护士或家庭健康或其他任何人的美元。它保持了特别是真实的，就像丝绸一样。它是该州许多地区和该国许多地区的经济支柱。你知道，我10年前坐在那里，所以也许它已经过时了，就是每一美元花在医疗保健上，都会产生经济活动。所以它变成了销售，然后会花在很多事情上
and you know, you pay your rent, you buy your food or whatever. But after- You go to the restaurant that's closing, you go to the hardware store that is in your town, you know, you have money to keep your house from falling into disrepair. You know, you can hire a carpenter, you can hire a plumber. You know, you can create jobs with the money
而且你知道，你付房租，你买食物或其他什么。但在之后——你去那家正在倒闭的餐馆，你去你镇上的五金店，你知道，你有钱让你的房子不至于年久失修。你知道，你可以雇一个木匠，你可以雇一个水管工。你知道，你可以用钱创造就业机会
that is being returned to the local economy. Well, every healthcare data creates firm data of economic activity, and every data spent on defense or military staff creates less than a data of economic activity. And if you were optimizing your funding to make the most money long term, you'd put it away on healthcare, obviously. So it's the truth that keeps a lot of local economies functioning is the fact that we can have, you know, a lot of toasts is the hospital is the biggest employer in town, both urban and rural areas, you know, most cities and most most cities in the US, so don't have a big university, or
正在返回当地经济的钱。嗯，每一项医疗保健数据都会产生经济活动的坚定数据，而每一项花在国防或军事人员上的数据产生的经济活动不到一个数据。如果你为了长期赚最多的钱而优化你的资金，你显然会把它花在医疗保健上。所以事实是，让许多当地经济保持运转的是这样一个事实，即我们可以拥有，你知道，很多吐司是医院是镇上最大的雇主，无论是城市还是农村地区，你知道，大多数城市和大多数大多数美国城市，所以没有一所大大学，或者
hospitals are the largest employers in the city. Our big hospital is the university. So if you if you color it out, all everything that is UAB in downtown Birmingham, you don't have a lot of downtown Birmingham left Oh boy The money is that's keeping my roots jobs afloat but it's keeping all this I was always deeper I'm a man to pay for stuff. You know, I'm talking about but I've even a blue essential care Don't get paid very much by either public or private private health care. You know, I'm I so Home health workers make less than they would make if they worked at a gas station. It's very important.
医院是城市中最大的雇主。我们的大医院是大学。所以如果你把它涂掉，所有在伯明翰市中心是UAB的一切，你剩下的伯明翰市中心就不多了。哦，男孩，钱是让我的根源工作维持下去的东西，但它让所有这些我一直更深，我是一个付钱买东西的人。你知道，我在谈论，但我甚至是一个蓝色的基本护理，无论是公共还是私人私人医疗保健，都没有得到很多报酬。你知道，我，所以我家庭健康工作者赚的钱比他们在加油站工作赚的钱还要少。这非常重要。
I talked to a woman a couple of months ago who was a home health worker for her mother, who's disabled and elderly. And so she wants to do that job. It's very important. She wants to take care of her mother, but she makes very less money than less money than she would take you almost literally whenever job um of the state and a firm house broker is obviously extremely important to keeping people in their homes well again certain money because it's cheaper to do homebats and it was to put somebody and bring nice in home that was focused in profitability um but we don't care you know we it. We don't pay people who do essential care,
几个月前我和一位女士谈过，她是她母亲的家庭健康工作者，她母亲残疾且年迈。所以她想做那份工作。这非常重要。她想照顾她的母亲，但她赚的钱比她几乎字面上无论什么工作都要少得多，嗯，该州和一家坚定的房屋经纪人显然对让人们留在家里非常重要，虽然再次确定钱，因为做家庭浴比把某人放在家里更便宜，这专注于盈利，嗯，但我们不在乎，你知道我们它。我们不付钱给做基本护理的人，
whether they're cell phone workers, home health folks, nurses, whatever. The money that's commensurate with you, value it, provide it. Without annotating our resources and the kind of really what I can do is rent to begin saying is like, lend out healthcare costs
无论是手机工作者、家庭健康人员、护士，还是其他什么人。钱与你相称，价值它，提供它。在不注释我们的资源和那种真正我能做的是租金开始说的是，借出医疗保健成本
and make people healthier long-term. Well, and two, I mean, if you're listening to this and you're like, I don't see myself ending up on Medicaid or, you know, I'm a therapist or a health care worker that doesn't take Medicaid, so I don't think this affects me and these kind of cuts over this long term that we've just passed on this bill and then the way that and the big, beautiful bill and then the way that that is going to de-incentivize states to fund Medicaid and probably result in a lot of
并使人们长期更健康。嗯，还有二，我的意思是，如果你正在听这个，并且你就像，我没看到自己最终会进入医疗补助计划，或者，你知道，我是一名治疗师或医疗保健工作者，不接受医疗补助计划，所以我认为这不会影响我，这些长期的削减，我们刚刚通过了这个法案，然后那种方式，以及那份宏伟、美丽的法案，然后那种方式将使各州失去资助医疗补助计划的动力，并可能导致很多
kind of secondary, you know, chilling effects and cuts. So this doesn't affect me. Yeah, I would make the argument that Medicaid existing and being funded is what puts the heat on private insurers to provide services. I mean, this is a pretty broad through line. It doesn't work exactly this way. But one of the ways that you track healthcare policy and benefits and what's going to is that, Blue Cross Federal follows Medicaid policy loosely, and then all of the state plans will follow over a couple of years what Blue Cross Federal is doing, the direction that it is going. And so even if you're not billing Medicaid,
那种次要的，你知道，寒蝉效应和削减。所以这不会影响我。是的，我会争辩说，医疗补助计划的存在和获得资助是给私人保险公司提供服务施加压力的原因。我的意思是，这是一条相当广泛的贯穿线。它并不完全是这样运作的。但你追踪医疗保健政策和福利以及将要发生的事情的方法之一是，蓝十字联邦松散地遵循医疗补助政策，然后所有的州计划将在几年内遵循蓝十字联邦正在做的事情，它正在发展的方向。所以即使你没有向医疗补助计划开账单，
even if you're not on Medicaid as a patient, cutting Medicaid will affect your healthcare and make it worse over the next decade. Can you say a little bit about that relationship and like how that works? Well, it's pretty complicated. I don't know that superinductors, I don't know that anybody do test wrong.
即使你作为病人不在医疗补助计划中，削减医疗补助计划也会影响你的医疗保健，并在未来十年内使其变得更糟。你能稍微谈谈那种关系以及它是如何运作的吗？嗯，这相当复杂。我不知道那些超级电感器，我不知道有人做测试错误。
But basically, with private insurance, it's sort of sort of bottom. They want to pay as little as possible and cover as many people as they can who don't spend money on it. Right, that's the trade off. Well, if you've worked as a provider, we certainly assume how much effort it takes to get even
但基本上，对于私人保险，它有点像底部。他们想尽可能少地支付，并覆盖尽可能多不花钱的人。对，这就是权衡。好吧，如果你曾作为提供者工作过，我们当然假设从保险公司那里获得哪怕是
the dollar from the insurance company. And a lot of the time, the price of the after-paying decreases relative to inflation year over year. And when you pay that money, it drops. I don't think it's unreasonable to expect that we'll see insurance companies quite advantage of the lower standards and lower minimums to reduce the amount of money relative to the cost of high skill credit over time. So yeah, it was with people. All of a sudden also you got this massive base of low income uninsured people
一美元需要付出多少努力。而且很多时候，支付后的价格相对于通货膨胀逐年下降。当你支付那笔钱时，它就会下降。我不认为期望我们会看到保险公司利用较低的标准和较低的最低限额来减少相对于医疗保健信贷成本的资金量是不合理的。所以是的，它和人们在一起。突然之间，你也有了这个庞大的低收入无保险人群
who again, will get sick, will back up debt and will go to the ER at the end of the day and all of a sudden the ER just set the people who the hospital can't take care of. It's, it's, it's, it's shooting ourselves in the foot. And ultimately, it's in service of giving people who have a lot of money, even more money, right? All the money that's coming from Medicaid, you know, the one trillion dollar cut to Medicaid is being used to subsidize along with a lot of deficit spending, uh, given, I think it was like $3 trillion in tax breaks, which
他们再次，会生病，会背负债务，最终会去急诊室，突然之间，急诊室只是医院无法照顾的人。这，这，这，这是在搬起石头砸自己的脚。归根结底，这是为了给那些有很多钱的人更多的钱，对吧？所有来自医疗补助计划的钱，你知道，对医疗补助计划的一万亿美元削减被用来补贴，连同大量的赤字支出，呃，给予，我想大约是3万亿美元的税收减免，这
disproportionately fell upon people making six figures a year into the into the millions. It's a direct to up them transfer of wealth from working people to the 1% and people who don't have very much money are the ones that suffer most directly as a result of the fact I have this down the road. And so just to speak to result of the fact I have a stomach. And so just to speak to some of the misinformation around why your representatives are cutting healthcare,
不成比例地落在了每年赚六位数到数百万美元的人身上。这是从劳动人民到1%的人的直接财富转移，而没有太多钱的人是由于我在这条路上有这个而受到最直接伤害的人。所以只是为了谈论由于我有一个胃而产生的结果。所以只是为了谈论
because I mean, a lot of the 20% of people on Medicaid in Alabama probably voted indirectly or directly to have it cut nationally and at a state level. So I mean, to kind of speak to some of the misinformation around this, like, you don't necessarily have to share my values as a social worker to understand that a lot of these arguments break down under scrutiny. Because when I hear things about like, well, you know,
一些关于为什么你的代表要削减医疗保健的错误信息，因为我的意思是，阿拉巴马州20%的医疗补助计划参与者可能间接或直接投票支持在全国和州一级削减它。所以我的意思是，为了谈论一些关于这个的错误信息，就像，你不一定非要分享我作为社会工作者的价值观，才能理解很多这些论点在审查下是站不住脚的。因为当我听到关于，好吧，你知道，
somehow, you know, trans healthcare is taking away things, these kids are just getting transitioned in kindergarten if they say the wrong thing, or illegal immigrants are somehow getting all of the healthcare and taking it away from you. That's why your policy is not very good. I mean, those arguments are sort of predicated on this idea that there is just so much cheap and available healthcare in America, that if you go outside, you'll just trip over healthcare
不知何故，你知道，跨性别医疗保健正在拿走东西，如果这些孩子说错了话，他们就会在幼儿园被过渡，或者非法移民不知何故得到了所有的医疗保健并从你那里拿走。这就是为什么你的政策不是很好。我的意思是，这些论点是基于这样一种想法，即美国有太多的廉价和可用的医疗保健，如果你走出去，你就会被医疗保健绊倒
services that people are just going to go in and just sort of get kidney dialysis for fun that don't need it or something. And that's why when I hear a lot of those arguments, it's like, this doesn't work. Have you ever tried to receive these services as somebody with Blue Cross? Can you say anything about that misinformation machine and how it functions? Yeah. In any point of that, no one's getting recreational health care. No one's going out there and getting heart surgery for fun.
服务，人们只是会进去，只是为了好玩而进行肾透析，而不需要它或类似的东西。这就是为什么当我听到很多那些论点时，就像，这行不通。你有没有尝试过作为蓝十字的某人接受这些服务？你能谈谈那个错误信息机器以及它是如何运作的吗？是的。在任何一点上，没有人得到娱乐性医疗保健。没有人出去为了好玩而做心脏手术。
People get health care for the most part, when they need health care. And people who don't go to the hospital a lot, need health care in a different kind of way, right? Maybe they need a social worker to help them figure out what's going on with their lives and kind of, uh, realign, uh, how they spend their time. But yeah, like, which is not as near as some game. In fact, so now, not only do you spend, uh, time for us here, the more providers you can have and the more quantitative hospital provider game. In fact, there's no money you spend on crime for us here. The more providers you can have, the more quantitative hospital providers there are. It is very productive.
人们在大多数情况下，在需要医疗保健时获得医疗保健。而那些不经常去医院的人，以一种不同的方式需要医疗保健，对吧？也许他们需要一名社会工作者来帮助他们弄清楚他们的生活中发生了什么，并以某种方式，呃，重新调整，呃，他们如何度过时间。但是的，就像，这并不像某些游戏那样接近。事实上，所以现在，你不仅花费，呃，我们的时间，你拥有的提供者越多，医院提供者的数量就越多。事实上，你花在犯罪上的钱越多，我们在这里。你拥有的提供者越多，医院提供者的数量就越多。这是非常有成效的。
And so, since it's flagrant, you know, this threat of undocumented or illegal aliens or whatever, that's one, that's not true. So, it's still an ace in the hole for healthcare to undocumented people, unless the state chooses to, and I think one of the first states to do that. So it's not happening at a bad month, not happening in Wisconsin. And it's our first week that's being thrown around to persuade people who don't know a lot about what's happening, and then we'll get them to vote against the things that shape their own lives. Well, they can see that it's getting worse. I mean, they look at healthcare and they realize that it sucks and they don't like it. And when, but the reasons that are getting worse
所以，既然它是公然的，你知道，这种无证或非法外星人或任何东西的威胁，那是一，那不是真的。所以，它仍然是无证人员医疗保健的王牌，除非州选择这样做，我认为这是第一个这样做的州之一。所以它没有在糟糕的月份发生，没有在威斯康星州发生。这是我们被用来劝说那些对正在发生的事情了解不多的人的第一周，然后我们会让他们投票反对塑造他们自己生活的事情。嗯，他们可以看到它正在变得更糟。我的意思是，他们看着医疗保健，他们意识到它很糟糕，他们不喜欢它。而当，但它正在变得更糟的原因
that are being sold to them are not real, you know. You're getting worse because everybody's a middle man and is trying to dodge with that money as possible. So people can pay it and then also then even as, as middle, but also as expensive care as possible. That's the whole tension there. And there's nobody even in the middle selling costs, guaranteeing care, making it a better place. But it's just a total, you know,
被卖给他们的不是真的，你知道。你变得更糟是因为每个人都是中间人，并且试图尽可能多地躲避那笔钱。所以人们可以支付它，然后甚至作为，作为中间人，但也尽可能昂贵的护理。这就是整个紧张局势。而且甚至没有人中间在销售成本，保证护理，使其成为一个更好的地方。但这只是一个完全的，你知道，
it's the guarantee has to go out there. Everybody's playing by a set of rules. We're trying to optimize for the environment line. And when everybody does that, you know, the bottom line memory is for the people who need help. It's a real exciting, as much money as possible for people who right now don't need a lot of healthcare. But eventually, you know, it all comes first, right? There's this phrase that they use in disability politics, they deal with temporary or whatever, which I like.
保证必须在那里。每个人都在按照一套规则行事。我们正在尝试优化环境线。当每个人都这样做时，你知道，底线记忆是为那些需要帮助的人准备的。这真的很令人兴奋，为那些现在不需要太多医疗保健的人尽可能多地赚钱。但最终，你知道，这一切都是第一位的，对吧？残疾政治中有一个他们使用的短语，他们处理临时的或任何东西，我喜欢。
Because, you know, then again, one fifth of us, so half of medical costs in the US in a given year come from 5% of the population and one fifth of the population is a Medicaid. But that population changes a lot year to year, right? Some years you have a kid, a lot of people have kids that go into the NICU or has complicated pregnancies. People get hit by cars, there's accidents.
因为，你知道，再一次，我们五分之一的人，所以美国一年中一半的医疗费用来自5%的人口，而五分之一的人口是医疗补助计划。但那个人口每年变化很大，对吧？有些年你有孩子，很多人有孩子进入新生儿重症监护室或有复杂的怀孕。人们被车撞了，有事故。
You can sat at work and break your arm or bust your leg. Like, you know, I met a guy who's a painter who paints houses and that's like his job. I return a little bit in the sailors and painting like at his job. Every service can happen to everybody and it did happen to a lot of us. There's a transient population that moves around year to year and nobody knows when it's going to come for them. So it's you investing in, you know, you're protecting yourself against the risk
你可以在工作中坐着，摔断手臂或摔断腿。就像，你知道，我遇到了一个画家，他画房子，那是他的工作。我回到水手和绘画，就像他的工作。每项服务都可能发生在每个人身上，而且它确实发生在我们很多人身上。有一个每年都在移动的短暂人口，没有人知道它什么时候会来找他们。所以这是你投资于，你知道，你正在保护自己免受风险
down the term of the future of really how you can't deserve, which will happen, rare of us at some point. And it tends, maybe you can help me understand something that I've not quite understood. It tends to be the people that are like learn basic economics that talk about healthcare like it is a market.
未来长期的真正你无法应得的，这会发生，我们中的少数人在某个时候。而且往往，也许你可以帮我理解一些我不太理解的事情。往往是那些像学习基础经济学的人谈论医疗保健就像它是一个市场一样。
And it lacks some features of a market like the ability to choose, the ability to have like multiple options. You know, if I'm having a heart attack in an ambulance, I'm not like, wait a minute, can I, or price visibility, you know, like a market you go in and you see these tomatoes cost $5 and these cost $7. So I'm going to choose between quality or quantity or whatever. If I'm having a heart attack in an ambulance, I'm not like, wait, how much is this going to cost me? What is the procedure that's going to be done?
它缺乏市场的一些特征，比如选择的能力，拥有多个选项的能力。你知道，如果我在救护车里心脏病发作，我不会像，等一下，我可以，或者价格可见性，你知道，就像一个市场，你进去，你看到这些西红柿要5美元，这些要7美元。所以我将在质量或数量或任何东西之间做出选择。如果我在救护车里心脏病发作，我不会像，等等，这要花我多少钱？将要进行的程序是什么？
Can I see the rates of the hospitals and the available doctors and then choose which one to go to? I don't understand how we can talk about health care like it's a market. It seems like markets need things like price transparency, multiple options, the ability to choose between them, like a market. So help me understand that one. Well, so there's a good push for price transparency. I'm going to give a general example over the past 10 years.
我能看到医院的费率和可用的医生，然后选择去哪一个吗？我不明白我们怎么能像谈论市场一样谈论医疗保健。看起来市场需要价格透明度、多个选项、在它们之间进行选择的能力，就像一个市场。所以帮我理解那个。嗯，所以有一个很好的价格透明度推动。我将在过去10年中举一个一般的例子。
In conception, I agree with that. We should know how much it costs to regret any kind of unit of healthcare. But when the providers put out the post-transparency lists, one, they'll do it as little as possible, right? The donor files are put out, they're very messy, very complicated. You're asked to spend a lot of time trying to listen to them,
在概念上，我同意这一点。我们应该知道后悔任何类型的医疗保健单位需要多少钱。但当提供者列出成本透明度列表时，一，他们会尽可能少地做，对吧？捐赠者文件被放出来，它们非常混乱，非常复杂。你被要求花很多时间试图听它们，
but you can't figure out how much stuff costs. And two, there are so many factors shaping how you get health care, where you get health care, that you can't use. And people, when studying studies, there are studies of what happens when there is such cross-transparency, people don't go to a shop around because they can't, because you've got a doctor that you see, and you kind of delegate that trace of what care you get and
但你无法弄清楚东西要多少钱。二，有太多的因素影响你如何获得医疗保健，你在哪里获得医疗保健，以至于你无法使用。而且人们，在研究研究时，有关于当存在这种交叉透明度时会发生什么的各种研究，人们不去货比三家，因为他们不能，因为你有一个你看到的医生，你把那种你得到什么护理的选择委托给那个医生，以及
where you get it to that doctor. So, I'm not saying even if you've got a chronic condition that requires five different things, like do you really want to, let's say you've got something, let's say you've got cancer, you really want to strap around to five different hospitals that don't talk to each other to figure out where you get every particular unit of cancer care? Of course not, that's ridiculous. One, that's very rare that an average person can do navigating all this data, and two, like if you have cancer and you're getting really high rate cancer, like if you have cancer, you have to be very refining cancer. You have to secure the rest of the capacity
你在哪里得到它给那个医生。所以，我甚至不是说如果你有一种需要五种不同东西的慢性病，你真的想，假设你有什么，假设你有癌症，你真的想在五家不互相交谈的医院之间货比三家，以弄清楚你在哪里得到每一项特定的癌症护理单位吗？当然不是，那太荒谬了。一，普通人能做到导航所有这些数据是非常罕见的，二，就像如果你有癌症，你正在得到非常高率的癌症，就像如果你有癌症，你必须非常精炼癌症。你必须确保其余的能力
you have to navigate at this paper, that can do all the shopping around. So we've seen that people don't shop around things. If you tried to get this cancer treatment here and this one here and actually price that stuff out, if you could figure out what it costs, you had the wherewithal, you had the transportation ability. I mean, those providers will not let you treat in that way.
你必须导航这个纸，那可以做所有的货比三家。所以我们已经看到人们不货比三家。如果你尝试在这里得到这种癌症治疗，在这里得到这种治疗，并实际定价那些东西，如果你能弄清楚它要多少钱，你有财力，你有交通能力。我的意思是，那些提供者不会让你以那种方式治疗。
I mean, they will drop you as a patient unless you're kind of getting these services as a bundle, as a part of complex care because of the way that medicine works, you know, that it needs to be integrated. And, and you just, you know, the system needs to know, you know, what treatments you've had and have all that kind of document. You know, but it's a whole idea that you can just stop third care or do price transparency and figure it out. Ultimately, the case scenario is like this, right?
我的意思是，他们会放弃你作为病人，除非你因为医学运作的方式而以捆绑的形式获得这些服务，作为复杂护理的一部分，你知道，它需要被整合。而且，而且你只是，你知道，系统需要知道，你知道，你接受过什么治疗，并拥有所有那种文件。你知道，但这整个想法是你只能停止第三次护理或进行价格透明度并弄清楚它。最终，案例场景是这样的，对吧？
You've got a kid, the kid is very sick, there's two jobs you can do with the kid. One, we'll bankrupt you, but the kid will get better. The second one, you can kind of move forward, you can stay out of it, but the kid might not get the best healthcare they can, they might not recover. So how do you choose? How do you ask, how do you plan to doctor with shoes? What's the prosperity? You clearly use really perverse incentives.
你有一个孩子，孩子病得很重，你可以用孩子做两份工作。一，会让你破产，但孩子会好起来。第二个，你可以以某种方式前进，你可以远离它，但孩子可能得不到他们能得到的最好的医疗保健，他们可能无法恢复。那么你如何选择？你如何问，你如何计划医生选择？什么是繁荣？你显然使用非常反常的激励措施。
Ultimately, we're being asked to choose between money or real life, like the pirates used to say. There is a lot of things like piracy happening and it's usually been grabbed by a pirate. But you can't ask somebody to make that decision. There's a lot of things like piracy happening. And it's usually good to get grabbed by a pirate. But you can't ask somebody to make that decision. That's not even a decision to make. The hostage was signed.
归根结底，我们被要求在金钱或现实生活之间做出选择，就像海盗过去常说的那样。有很多像海盗行为的事情正在发生，而且它通常被海盗抓住。但你不能要求某人做出那个决定。有很多像海盗行为的事情正在发生。而且通常被海盗抓住是好的。但你不能要求某人做出那个决定。那甚至不是一个决定。人质被签署了。
It isn't a market. You see whether or not you die lacks some of the essential features of a market also. I'm sure not to buy tomatoes this week. I can choose that I'm not going to make red sauce for my life. I can go ahead and make a salad or whatever instead. Can I really choose to go where I want my kid to make red cells for my life. I can go ahead and make a salad out of it instead. Can I really choose to go
它不是一个市场。你是否死亡缺乏市场的一些基本特征。我确定这周不买西红柿。我可以选择我不为我的生活做红酱。我可以继续做沙拉或其他什么。我真的可以选择去我想让我的孩子为我的生活做红酱的地方吗？我可以继续做沙拉。我真的可以选择去
whether I want my kid to live or die? No, I'm a captive audience. I mean, in fact, you shouldn't have to worry about whether you go bankrupt for your kid being sick or whatever. That's the duration of phasing upon a lot of people and you don't have freedom of choice. You can't have freedom of choice in healthcare.
我想让我的孩子活还是死吗？不，我是个被俘虏的观众。我的意思是，事实上，你不应该担心你的孩子生病或其他什么你会破产。那是对很多人施加的持续时间，你没有选择的自由。你在医疗保健中不能有选择的自由。
I must say, one of the choices available is to die, which I don't think really counts as a market decision. The structure of services with shared healthcare are well beyond the capacity of an individual consumer to navigate. That's how we have new systems and carries to help make steps work for people. And they're not doing their job.
我必须说，可用的选择之一是死亡，我认为这并不真正算作市场决策。共享医疗保健的服务结构远远超出了个人消费者的导航能力。这就是我们有新系统和携带者来帮助人们使步骤工作的方式。而且他们没有做好他们的工作。
They're inadequate to get their job done. When, because they're too small, perversely, to get the cost and optimization process that they need, or the integrated healthcare that you need to provide. And two, because they don't have a mentor. Because they make a ton of money at the end of the year. You get a good healthcare, you know, I guess their parents and their grandparents, so they're in there, I don't actually know about them by hand, but they're making more money than God every single year,
他们不足以完成他们的工作。当，因为他们太小，反常地，无法获得他们需要的成本和优化过程，或者你需要的综合医疗保健来提供。二，因为他们没有导师。因为他们在年底赚了很多钱。你得到一个好的医疗保健，你知道，我猜他们的父母和祖父母，所以他们在那里，我实际上不知道他们手头的情况，但他们每年赚的钱比上帝还多，
hand over fist, and so at the end of the day, you're being denied the care you need, will you do it or are you losing your insurance? Everybody wins except for the person to part in the healthcare system. So just to kind of close out, could you tell us some of the like maybe stories you've collected about the kind of
手忙脚乱，所以归根结底，你被拒绝了你需要的护理，你会做吗，还是你失去了你的保险？每个人都赢了，除了在医疗保健系统中部分的人。所以只是为了结束，你能告诉我们一些你收集的关于那种的故事吗？
absurdities and redundancies and when you introduce private equity into these systems and the perverse incentive structures? Because I mean, there is kind of some bleakly comic stuff, you know. I, one of my members of my family works, you know, approving SSDI in one of the offices. And one of the things that he still has to works, you know, approving SSDI in one of the offices. And one of the things that he still has to do, you know, to prove disability is to prove that somebody couldn't work as a magnetic tapewinder or a typewriter repairman. Those are two skills that, you know,
荒谬和冗余，以及当你将私募股权引入这些系统和反常的激励结构时？因为我的意思是，有一种阴郁的喜剧东西，你知道。我，我的一个家庭成员工作，你知道，在其中一个办公室批准SSDI。而他仍然必须做的事情之一，你知道，批准SSDI在其中一个办公室。而他仍然必须做的事情之一，你知道，为了证明残疾，就是证明某人不能作为磁带卷绕机或打字机修理工工作。这是两项技能，你知道，
you have to rule out that the person is not able to do because there's such a burgeoning industry of typewriter repair where they may be able to get slimming if they weren't on disability. You know, there's some a burgeoning industry of typewriter repair where they may be able to get swimming if they weren't on disability. You know, there's some wild stuff in there. Do you have any of those? Can you read Gail's? I got one example. I got a daddy in New Jersey named Steve, and Steve has master of industry fate, right?
你必须排除那个人不能做，因为有一个如此蓬勃发展的打字机修理行业，如果他们没有残疾，他们可能能够得到瘦身。你知道，那里有一些狂野的东西。你有那些吗？你能读盖尔的吗？我有一个例子。我在新泽西州有一个叫史蒂夫的爸爸，史蒂夫有工业命运大师，对吧？
Very similar to when dad was eating himself. He weighed something like 90 pounds, moved over the wheelchair. The rise of Stephanie Seward at birth was 18 years. He's probably 32 or 33. So Steve's talking along through the two children, the seventh can be ruined. We spend our time on TV as we're after. And every, Steve needs help out.
这和爸爸以前自己吃饭时非常像。他当时体重大概90磅，挪动轮椅都很费劲。斯蒂芬妮·苏厄德出生时是18岁。他现在大概32或33岁。所以史蒂夫在两个孩子之间谈论着，第七个孩子可能会被毁掉。我们把时间花在电视上，因为我们在追求它。而且史蒂夫每件事都需要帮助。
Steve needs a pilot wheelchair. And Steve needs somebody to come over every month, every day, and help him feed himself, go with himself, go to the bathroom, stuff like that. It's just the way it is. It's nice. It's fine. Because of the little service that Steve can learn, and learn a dignified life, and do the work you have to do, everybody benefits. But every two months, Blue Cross sends a match to
史蒂夫需要一辆电动轮椅。史蒂夫需要有人每个月、每天都过来，帮他吃饭、照顾自己、上厕所之类的。事情就是这样。这很好。没问题。因为史蒂夫可以学习这些小服务，过上有尊严的生活，做他必须做的工作，每个人都能受益。但每两个月，蓝十字保险公司就会派人去
his house to check and see if he's still reserving and still qualified for care. So I imagine there's some expense, you know, gotta pay her salary or his salary. That's great. And also the process of doing all the paperwork to check and done a check and should check is, it's time, so it costs, it costs money. But yeah, Steve is a service servant.
他家检查，看看他是否还在接受护理，是否仍有资格获得护理。所以我猜这会有一些开销，你知道，得支付她或他的工资。这很好。而且处理所有文书工作来核实、检查和再次检查的过程，这需要时间，所以这会花费金钱。但是的，史蒂夫是一个服务对象。
He hasn't suddenly cured active muscular dystrophy and then doing the work and use his hands and stuff. It'd be pretty miraculous if the nurse came and all of a sudden, a degenerative condition had gone away. They're spending a lot of money to assess every month if a miracle has taken place. It's something like he didn't
他并没有突然治愈了进行性肌营养不良，然后就能干活、用手做事了。如果护士来了，一种退行性疾病突然消失了，那将是非常奇迹的事情。他们花了很多钱每个月去评估是否发生了奇迹。这就像他没有
get any care because of it, right? It still takes Blue Cross half a year to approve a fix to his wheelchair if it breaks. It's not like they're doing anything about consider out of concern their investment in the long-term care. It's just a way of common care whenever possible. Because now Steve has to set up that appointment to have to sync up in time. in his long-term care, it's just a way of common care whenever possible.
因为这个而得到任何护理，对吧？蓝十字保险公司如果他的轮椅坏了，修复它仍然需要半年时间。他们并不是出于对长期护理投资的关心而做任何事情。这只是尽可能采用通用护理的一种方式。因为现在史蒂夫必须安排那个预约，必须在时间上同步。在他的长期护理中，这只是尽可能采用通用护理的一种方式。
Because now Steve has to set up that appointment, he has to sync up in time. And like sure, Steve's lucky that he can do these things, he's got heart. But some of the folks that they can't, there was an accident, or they missed their stand, or they can't get on their stand, or they can't get on their stand, or they're moving or whatever. And so they had a reason to miss the appointment, and all of a sudden, bam, they're not getting the care they need to that month. This happens all the time across the country.
因为现在史蒂夫必须安排那个预约，他必须在时间上同步。当然，史蒂夫很幸运，他能做这些事情，他很有勇气。但有些无法做到的人，比如发生了事故，或者错过了他们的预约，或者无法到达预约地点，或者他们正在搬家等等。所以他们有理由错过预约，突然之间，砰，他们那个月就得不到所需的护理了。这种情况在全国各地时有发生。
And it's a very silly way, very stupid way, I think, of arranging a healthcare system. Well, I mean, one of the things that I think is the way that you get away with kind of crimes in the American political system is that you find something that's pretty bipartisan, that if you just ask 80% of the country on the street, 90% of the country, do you agree with this? They would be like, yeah, of course. If you do that, you're going to get this result. I want that result, so why would we do this thing? But then you find some way to split that constituency by picking something that's aesthetic or a
我认为这是一种非常愚蠢、非常荒谬的安排医疗保健系统的方式。我的意思是，我认为在美国政治体系中，你能够逃脱某种罪行的方法之一，就是找到一些相当两党一致的事情，如果你在街上问80%或90%的国民，你同意这个吗？他们会说，是的，当然。如果你这样做，你就会得到这个结果。我想要那个结果，那我们为什么要这样做呢？但随后你会找到某种方法来分裂选民，通过选择一些美学上的或者
cultural value, religious value, or you know, some part of spectacle and aesthetics to make sure that these people can't have political capital because they won't agree, they won't vote for the same person. And you know, something like price transparency, like we had a price transparency in healthcare bill that sailed through Alabama and everybody was broadly in support of it. And they were saying like, you know, no more surprise billing, you know. So there's all this paperwork on me now as a therapist to tell the patient all these things that are already kind of self-evident and they would know like
文化价值、宗教价值，或者你知道，某种奇观和美学，以确保这些人无法拥有政治资本，因为他们不会同意，他们不会投票给同一个人。你知道，像价格透明度这样的事情，我们有一项医疗保健价格透明度法案，在阿拉巴马州顺利通过，每个人都广泛支持它。他们说，你知道，不再有意外账单，你知道。所以现在作为治疗师，我有很多文书工作要做，要告诉病人所有这些已经不言自明的事情，他们会知道，比如
you're if you're on a sliding scale with me and we have a sliding scale at my practice so if you make under $30,000 a year then I'm only $80 to see for you know complex trauma therapy we can generally get complex trauma treated with brain-based medicine pretty quickly or you, if you make $40,000 a year, I'm 85 or $90 to see. I don't have my sliding scale memorized, but so the price transparency bill was like, no surprise billing, you got to tell these people every three months, exactly how much they're going to pay. Well, it's pretty simple to understand a sliding scale or a private pay rate
如果你在我的诊所使用浮动收费标准，我们确实有浮动收费标准，所以如果你年收入低于3万美元，那么我看你一次只需要80美元，你知道，复杂的创伤治疗，我们通常可以很快用基于大脑的医学治疗复杂创伤，或者，如果你年收入4万美元，我看你一次是85或90美元。我没有背下我的浮动收费标准，但价格透明度法案的意思是，没有意外账单，你必须每三个月告诉这些人他们到底要付多少钱。好吧，理解浮动收费标准或私人支付费率其实很简单
because you know what the price is for every hour that you come see me. It's going to be this. But that bill doesn't apply to insurance. Insurance doesn't have to do that. It's only private pay services on a sliding scale. Like the insurance industry made sure that you don't have price transparency, that this law doesn't apply to them in Alabama. And so a lot of the time it's the people that are getting hit with a surprise with me because
因为你知道你每次来看我一小时的价格。就是这个价格。但该法案不适用于保险。保险公司不必这样做。它只适用于浮动收费标准下的私人支付服务。就像保险业确保你没有价格透明度，这项法律在阿拉巴马州不适用于他们。所以很多时候，在我这里遇到意外账单的人是那些
they thought that they had mental health coverage for Blue Cross said, oh, actually you can't have rape counseling because you didn't get blood work this year and have a PCP visit for primary care. So your prior authorization can't be approved, something like that. What are like broadly bipartisan and just obvious things that most people would agree with that we could do tomorrow if anyone wanted to. I mean, I think through that to give you some very specific answers. But ultimately, you know, having a central authority
他们以为自己有心理健康保险，但蓝十字保险公司说，哦，实际上你不能进行强奸咨询，因为你今年没有做血液检查，也没有进行初级保健的PCP访问。所以你的预先授权无法批准，类似这样的事情。有哪些广泛的两党一致且显而易见的事情，如果有人想做，我们明天就可以做？我的意思是，我想通过这些来给你一些非常具体的答案。但归根结底，你知道，拥有一个中央权威
that can help bring down the infirmary costs and make a mistake. Right now, we've got a discrepan said between all the paperwork people have at the hospital and all the paperwork people at the insurance company. And these divisions, these jobs just, you know, man, man, man over here, as both sides find the way, it's just through the other. We can simplify that, you know? You can say, listen, Medicare pays 100 bios for your shots,
可以帮助降低医疗成本并减少错误。现在，我们在医院的文书工作和保险公司的文书工作之间存在差异。这些部门，这些工作，你知道，伙计，伙计，伙计在这里，双方都在寻找方法，这只是通过对方。我们可以简化这一点，你知道吗？你可以说，听着，联邦医疗保险为你的注射支付100美元，
for glass for your shots, and the bills that operate as a function of that. You agree, I'm gonna pay 110% of Medicare or whatever. Well, there are things you can do to help streamline and regulate the way that pricing works. Now, you actually can tell what's going to cost, which I know you can't do. There are some things that I think are popular. You know, I've been talking about things like Medicare for all. Everyone with a job with people, remember how to extend them,
为你的注射提供玻璃，而账单是作为其功能运作的。你同意，我将支付联邦医疗保险的110%或类似金额。好吧，你可以做一些事情来帮助精简和规范定价运作的方式。现在，你实际上可以知道成本是多少，我知道你做不到。有些事情我认为很受欢迎。你知道，我一直在谈论像全民医保这样的事情。每个有工作的人，记得如何扩展它们，
or infer them, things like Medicare for all. Everyone with a job with people, I remember how to extend them on further things like Medicare for all. It's not necessarily a universal, I pass an issue, but it's got a lot more support across the spectrum than people anticipate. There's just a lot of stuff that like, everyone knows they're being screwed. That's the thing I found whenever I talk to anybody, any part of the country, everybody knows they're being screwed and somewhere by the healthcare, like healthcare structure, with them or somebody that they love or somewhere that they're close to. Nobody was far. Nobody was wherever one or two of you was removed from somebody who's been really screwed over by this whole arrangement. And then big things and there are small things you can
或者推断它们，像全民医保这样的事情。它不一定是一个普遍的、我通过的问题，但它在整个范围内得到的支持比人们预期的要多得多。有很多事情，每个人都知道他们被坑了。这是我无论在全国任何地方与任何人交谈时发现的事情，每个人都知道他们在某个地方被医疗保健结构坑了，无论是他们自己还是他们爱的人，或者他们亲近的人。没有人离得很远。没有人离那些被整个安排严重坑害的人有一两步之遥。还有一些大的事情和一些小的你可以
do to hack away at it. Rob knows it's going to cost somebody the profit so we don't do it. But yeah, there's lots of kinds of regulations that are composed in big and small ways. What I'm working on right now in Wisconsin is the hospital is non-profit, if it gets all kinds of tax breaks. It's supposed to, in theory, spend money whether it's paying taxes on providing community care.
做的事情来削减它。罗伯知道这会花费某人的利润，所以我们不这样做。但是的，有很多种法规以大大小小的方式组成。我现在在威斯康星州所做的工作是，医院是非营利性的，如果它获得了各种税收减免。理论上，它应该把支付税款的钱花在提供社区护理上。
Or going out to the neighborhoods and small areas that are underserved and taxes on providing community care. Or when they're going out to the neighborhoods and small areas that are underserved and help them get them health care, providing charity care for really low-income people. And they don't, and there's no regulation whatsoever. So we've got hospitals that receives running just 30 million dollars more in tax breaks than they spend on community benefits.
或者去那些服务不足的社区和小地区，把税款花在提供社区护理上。或者当他们去那些服务不足的社区和小地区，帮助他们获得医疗保健，为真正的低收入人群提供慈善护理。但他们没有这样做，而且没有任何监管。所以我们有医院获得的税收减免比他们花在社区福利上的钱多出3000万美元。
That's a clear provision of this whole agreement that we have to why hospitals are nonprofit. And they don't do it, you know, they don't do it. And so as I mentioned at that, which is something we've talked about the rules, we've already established, I think we're seeing real brand momentum towards that over the next few years. I have kind of a theory that has to do with like the graphic user interface of things. That if something is like an optional service that you don't really need, they make it incredibly easy to do.
这是我们关于医院为何是非营利性机构的整个协议中明确的规定。但他们没有这样做，你知道，他们没有这样做。正如我提到的那样，这是我们讨论过的规则，我认为我们已经看到了未来几年朝着这个方向发展的真正品牌势头。我有一种理论，与事物的图形用户界面有关。如果某件事是你不真正需要的可选服务，他们会让你操作起来极其简单。
Whereas if something's a mandatory service that everyone has to do, then they're able to harass you through the user interface. At a gas pump, gas pumps, they don't work great. You have to put the thing in the right order and put the hose back. It can show you ads. It can blare advertise because you have to get gas, you're not going to drive away. But you know, you can easily, you know, doing insurance claims or insurance reimbursement or under even understanding your benefits as somebody who pays for them as a patient, somebody you network with insurance, like you, that stuff is the most complicated,
而如果某件事是每个人都必须做的强制性服务，那么他们就能通过用户界面骚扰你。在加油站，加油泵，它们工作得并不好。你必须按正确的顺序放入东西并放回软管。它可以向你展示广告。它可以播放广告，因为你必须加油，你不会开车离开。但你知道，你可以轻松地，你知道，处理保险索赔或保险报销，甚至作为一名患者理解你的福利，作为与保险网络合作的人，像你一样，那些东西是世界上最复杂、
hard thing in the world to use. And, you know, there's no kind of universal app that just says like, hey, here's the doctors that cover you around here. Here's how much your benefits cover. Hey, your GPS says that it looks like you're at a clinic that's not covered. Do you want to file a prior authorization if you're doing a visit here? You know, here's places in your zip code. I mean, you can, but while it's incredibly easy to say, well, I can't afford this 1999 pizza from Pizza Hut, but this little app is going to go ahead and run my credit, let me finance that over six months. I mean, I can finance a pizza easier than I can understand my healthcare benefits.
最难使用的东西。而且，你知道，没有那种通用的应用程序说，嘿，这是你周围覆盖你的医生。这是你的福利覆盖多少。嘿，你的GPS显示你似乎在一家不在覆盖范围内的诊所。如果你在这里就诊，你想提交预先授权吗？你知道，这是你邮政编码里的地方。我的意思是，你可以，但虽然说“我负担不起必胜客这19.99美元的比萨”非常容易，但这个小应用程序会继续运行我的信用，让我分六个月支付。我的意思是，我分期付款买比萨比理解我的医疗福利更容易。
You know, I actually know people that are providing the hospital, people that are paying for it, don't know how much that was in the cost until it goes through the entire machine. I asked even an insurance company how much does it cost to get you, you know, hand amputated or whatever. Impossible to know. There's so much building to you, loads of paperwork and processing that you can't even predict these prices ahead of time. It's just the whole model is too complicated to play out as simple as like, you know, a menu. And so you have to simplify it. How much of this stuff do you think is just stupidity and how much of, you know, the stupidity of bureaucracy and how much of it do you think is intentional?
你知道，我确实认识一些提供医院服务的人，支付费用的人，在整个机器运行之前都不知道成本是多少。我问过保险公司，切除手之类的手术要花多少钱。根本无法知道。有太多的账单、大量的文书工作和处理过程，你甚至无法提前预测这些价格。整个模式太复杂了，无法像菜单那样简单地运作。所以你必须简化它。你认为这些东西有多少是愚蠢，有多少是官僚主义的愚蠢，又有多少是你认为是有意的？
It's not just a series of accidents that kind of roll down here, like a stone that I've been mastered with them, right? And sure, when I find a road to a pair of little as possible, the hospital is going to find a way to pairs with this path, whether it's a hospital, when I find a road that charges as possible. And so they've got like, it's like, you know, one guy who makes a move with a little bit of a kind of move and they go back instead of building this massive structure around it.
这不仅仅是一系列滚落到这里的事故，就像我掌握的一块石头，对吧？当然，当我找到一条尽可能少付钱的路时，医院会找到一种方法来应对这条路，无论是医院，当我找到一条收费尽可能高的路时。所以他们有，就像，你知道，一个人做了一个动作，带有一点动作，他们就回去了，而不是围绕它建立这个巨大的结构。
It's just, it's a road that circles fast and we try to push them around and land potions to come in the middle. Yeah. Well, that was wonderful and you really have a lot of experience. I appreciate your time there. Is there anything that we don't get to or you think is kind of a good cap to that?
这只是一条快速循环的道路，我们试图把他们推来推去，让药水进入中间。是的。好吧，这太棒了，你确实有很多经验。我很感谢你花时间在这里。有什么我们没有涉及到的，或者你认为是一个很好的总结吗？
That's absolutely a good point you're talking to. This is very fun. Is there anything that we can link to or help you promote? Some of your articles or you work on anything now, would you like people to be able to click on in the show notes if they want to find out more about what you do? I've read a newsletter that I write very infugable about healthcare issues.
你说的这一点绝对很好。这非常有趣。有什么我们可以链接到或帮助你推广的吗？你的一些文章或者你现在正在做的任何工作，如果你希望人们在想了解更多关于你的工作时，能够在节目说明中点击它们？我写了一份关于医疗保健问题的时事通讯，写得非常详尽。
Right now I'm focusing on stuff I've read. I'm working on some books that was found in there. I picked a really dumb name for it. It's pardonjohn.com slash error. I'll write the user name which says, I read everything to do with it. You can write to that if you wanted to. Well, great. Well, thank you so much.
现在我专注于我读过的东西。我正在写一些在里面发现的书。我给它起了一个非常愚蠢的名字。它是pardonjohn.com/error。我会写下用户名，上面写着，我读了所有与之相关的东西。如果你愿意，你可以写信给那个地址。好吧，太棒了。非常感谢你。
I really appreciate your time here and it's been wonderful speaking with you. Tim Fowles, thank you so much for joining us and there'll be more that you can click on below if you want to find out anything else about what Tim does or how these things work. Thanks for having me. I love to hear their Democrats when they're partying all night long Love to hear their sacred scent when they're saluting their favourite song
我真的很感谢你花时间在这里，和你交谈真是太棒了。蒂姆·福尔斯，非常感谢你的加入，如果你想了解更多关于蒂姆所做的事情或这些事情是如何运作的，下面会有更多你可以点击的内容。谢谢你邀请我。我喜欢听民主党人在整夜聚会时，喜欢听他们唱他们最喜欢的歌时的神圣歌声
Left, right, left, right, stomping down all through the night Left, right, left, right, stomping down all through the night Left, right, left, right, now I've got you in my sights Left, right, left, right, did you get the money right? Of course you know what we need Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
左，右，左，右，整夜跺脚，左，右，左，右，整夜跺脚，左，右，左，右，现在我把你锁定在我的视线里，左，右，左，右，你把钱算对了吗？当然你知道我们需要什么，谢谢观看！本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。